are exhausted after all we have been
through and even as the delta strain is
still circulating we are all alarmed by
how quickly omicron has spread and
anxious about what is next
people back in my home state of
washington and across the country are
frustrated and worried about the course
of this pandemic and its persistent
challenges
like how hard it still is to get a test
i've heard from so many people who are
waiting in long lines and going from
pharmacy to pharmacy trying to find a
test
or who are giving up on getting tested
because tests are unavailable or cost
too much
i've also heard from people who have
found the communication about new
isolation and quarantined guidance
confusing
and frustrating
they are trying to keep themselves and
their families safe as this pandemic
evolves and we continue to learn more
but i'm hearing more and more questions
like what kind of test should i get when
should i get tested why can't i find a
test do i need to isolate ten days five
days or even at all
testing in particular is a huge concern
for parents who are starting 2022
exhausted from the last two years and
worried about schools staying open
safely this year
i know what a struggle it is for parents
scrambling to figure out child care when
they've got to go to work or how tough
it is for kids to keep up with classwork
while transitioning back and forth from
in-person to online learning
and while most schools are still safely
open for in-person learning and we all
want to make sure they stay that way we
know schools are struggling with this
especially as omicron creates new
challenges
i'm hearing from schools in my states
that they're worried they'll have to
shut down again if they can't get the
support for testing they need or they
have staff shortages because of staff
who are ill
nobody wants that and based on what we
now know about this virus and the tools
we have to fight it schools should be
able to stay open safely if they have
tests masks ventilation and people are
vaccinated
hospital and health care providers are
worried too they've been stretched to
thin after two exhausting years and now
omicron is causing the worst surge in
cases and hospitalizations yet
because while it may be less severe in
most cases especially for those who are
vaccinated and boosted it is so much
more contagious meaning we are still
seeing high rates of hospitalization
overall
and we also have to protect children who
are too young to get vaccinated and
people with health conditions and
disabilities that put them at high risk
back in my state hospitals are asking
our state leaders to declare a crisis
for our medical facilities
i've heard from health care providers in
washington who have been well over their
staffed bed capacity for several days
and are pausing non-essential procedures
families are wondering whether they can
get care for non-coveted related
conditions and alarmed by how long er
wait times are getting
healthcare providers are concerned about
how we continue to keep healthcare
workers safe and also address the
fatigue and burnout and mental health
challenges that they face
these are not new challenges i've been
raising many of these con concerns since
the earliest days of the pandemic
so i'm frustrated we're still behind on
issues as important to families as
testing and supporting schools
that's not to say we have not made
progress it's just clear we haven't made
enough
but even though we aren't where we need
to be yet we are not back at the
starting line when it comes to cover 19
either
we have safe and effective vaccines for
everyone ages 5 and up we have booster
shots available for those 12 and up
more and more people are getting their
shots each day
the administration is also working to
help get the world vaccinated to end
this pandemic and has already pledged
over a billion vaccine doses to that
effort
we have new life-saving therapeutics we
have additional resources congress
passed in the american rescue plan which
can help increase our testing capacity
protect workers and give schools the
support they need to stay
safely open
and we have an administration that is
focused on following the science facing
this pandemic head-on and addressing the
frustration people are feeling that is
crucial at this moment when the path
forward requires steady leadership and
clear communication about the challenges
we are still facing and the work ahead
to tackle them
president biden has said plainly that he
shares families frustration around
testing and he wants to make sure
schools stay safely open
and he has announced steps to address
these challenges by making 500 million
tests available free of charge
ordering over 200 million courses of
antivirals
expanding manufacturing to be able to
make hundreds of millions of tests a
month
providing schools with guidance on how
to test to stay protocols which can help
keep students in the classroom
standing up more testing and vaccination
sites across the country and providing
medical personnel to struggling areas
i expect to hear more detail on those
efforts today along with what other
steps the administration plans to take
and i will be watching closely as they
are implemented but i also want to be
clear when we talk about these problems
we have to be focused on solutions
you can't just say our schools must stay
open if you don't vote to provide
additional resources schools need to do
so
you can't just say the latest health
guidance is confusing and not call out
the blatant misinformation that has come
from so many members of the republican
party
we're not going to get out of this
crisis by treating each challenge as a
political opportunity we're going to get
through it by being honest about what we
are facing and clear about what we are
going to do about it
and as we continue working to get
through this pandemic it's important we
also look at what we can do to prevent
future health crises that is exactly why
senator burr and i have been working in
a bipartisan way over the last several
months on legislation to learn from and
improve on our pandemic response
like strengthening our supply chain for
medical products
updating old and incompatible public
health data systems
modernizing the process for developing
tests
fighting misinformation addressing root
causes of health inequities and more
we will be unveiling a discussion draft
soon and i look forward to working with
all of our colleagues to finalize and
pass this important package
in the meantime we will continue working
to address the pandemic at hand
people across the country are worried
this will be another year of uncertainty
uncertainty for their work their schools
and their everyday lives but there's no
reason it should be people should be
able to make plans for the future
without fearing that everything they are
looking forward to or even the everyday
things they used to take for granted
will be appended by this virus we all
want that and we have the tools we need
to get us there we have the tools to get
everyone tested quickly easily and for
free to keep schools safely open during
the omicron surge and beyond to keep
workers especially our health care
workers safe and healthy in the
workplace
we have the tools to mitigate this virus
to protect those at high risk like
seniors or kids who are too young to get
vaccinated and people with other health
conditions
to get people back to their friends and
their lives and to give families back
some certainty and stability we can do
all this now thanks to the incredibly
hard work on the part of health care
providers and scientists parents and
teachers workers
and our witnesses who are here with us
today so what i hope to hear from this
administration at this hearing is what
are you doing right now to make sure
every american can make use of that
progress they've worked so hard for
what can my constituents expect to see
improve this week
and the week after we've come a long way
since the start of this pandemic
and i look forward to hearing from each
of you today about what you're going to
do to build on what we know
bring this virus under control and bring
certainty and stability back to families
who are burnt out after two years of
fighting this pandemic
thank you and with that i will turn it
over to ranking member burr for his
opening remarks
madam chairman thank you and before my
opening statement i hope the chair will
indulge with me for just a second since
this is a hearing on preparation
i want to help my good friend senator
kane
as he gets ready for his weekly travels
i want to make sure that he's got an
orange for his car
that he's got a dr pepper
and i've provided a lumpy blanket
to make sure that these are three things
you've got in your car regardless of
what you run into on i-95
and i'll have my staff bring them over
to you i hope you provide those for
everyone as we used to say to our kids
in the classroom do you have a piece of
gum for everyone
well in his particular case i think he's
the only one that makes that trip on a
weekly basis tim we're sorry you had to
spend 27 hours but you're now qualified
to be the secretary of transportation if
you looking for a second job thank you
it's it's sad when a career in the
senate's uh most notable highlight is my
long commute but
um madam chairman thank you for holding
this hearing to our witnesses welcome
back
today is going to be a tough hearing
but the american people deserve
accountability and transparency
i appreciate that all of you have
cleared your schedules to allow multiple
rounds of questions today
next week marks one year of this
administration it also marks two years
since the first covid case was confirmed
president biden said in his first second
and third and third priorities would be
bringing
us out of covet pandemic and that his
team would shut down the virus
this administration was lucky it started
off on day one with the tools to change
the trajectory of covid response
operation warp speed
worked with the private sector to bring
us groundbreaking vaccines and
treatments in record time
although we had a very bumpy start with
testing early in the pandemic we
successfully built some strong
partnerships with the private sector to
support the development and
manufacturing of more tests
state and local leaders were rising to
the challenge of testing and vaccinating
their citizens
there was reason for hope
instead now a full year later here's
where we are more than 830 000 deaths
caused by covet the majority of which
occurred under this administration
despite having many tools and
significant resources from congress
including 80 billion dollars plus for
testing a variant is now spreading out
of control across the country with
places like washington dc
seeing a staggering increase in case
counts over the holidays and now my
state of north carolina is following
suit with a 319 percent increase as of
yesterday over the holidays when
americans were instructed to do the
responsible thing and get tests before
they see loved ones there were no tests
on the shelves or online and hours long
lines were the norm at testing sites
across the country the testing situation
was worse
when many sought tests to safely return
to work or to school
and the most vulnerable americans who
contracted the virus could not get the
treatments designed to help because they
were now in short supply
this administration has time and again
squandered its opportunities are made
worse
in the decisions you've made on testing
and treatment and most crucially in
communications with the american people
the american people are right to be
confused
it seems like
you all don't talk amongst yourself
some examples
last august the president announced that
boosters would be available to all
vaxxed
by the week of september twentieth
three of you here today signed that
statement but neither the fda nor the
cdc had yet approved boosters when the
president made the promise
and when you went to your advisory
panels with a predetermined outcome
already made those independent experts
pushed back and ultimately had to be
overridden to meet the president's goal
on boosters
i know the data shows that boosters are
necessary i'm boosted
i want everybody to get vaccinated and
boosted the facts about the value of
vaccines and booster are crystal clear
but the way this administration rolled
out boosters was a disaster
you created skepticism
and mass confusion
example two last summer the president
dramatically and dramatically announced
that cdc recommendations changed so that
vaccinated americans didn't need to wear
mask indoors
implying that the worst of the pandemic
was behind us even as the delta variant
was exploding in india
only after delta hit america did cdc
begin to take it seriously and the
administration had to change course
example three
last week dr fauci said that the cdc was
going to update its guidance on
quarantine he left the american people
with the impression that cdc's guidance
was going to include some testing
component
to reduce the quarantine to five days
but when cdc did update its guidance
there wasn't a testing requirement
again i'm not questioning the signs i'm
glad you refrained from testing mandates
but i'm questioning your communication
strategies
it's no wonder
the american don't wonder that the
american people are confused when the
president announced on december 21st
that 500 million tests were going to be
purchased he left out that the contract
wasn't going to be signed for weeks and
it would take even longer for those
tests to be to to materialize
immediately other experts and medical
professionals were asking what the value
of just 1.5 tests per person was when
cdc's own guidance said that you need
multiple at-home tests to be assured
of the results
yesterday the administration mandated
that insurers now cover the 170 million
americans that are covered by private
insurance
they must cover up to eight tests per
person per month
that would be 16 billion tests
and we have 500 million today
that
are aspirationally going to be
contracted for it's still unclear when
these tests will be available how to get
them
whether any more are on their way but
it's especially frustrating that the
white house press secretary had
previously mocked the very idea of doing
what the president later announced in a
sarcastic and withering tone when this
was first proposed she had four
questions whether we should just send
one to every american
then what happens
how much does it cost
what happens after that
those are all good questions that remain
unanswered by the administration
my final example though there are many
to choose from
happened last week too
the white house press secretary
a repeat offender in poor communications
was asked about boosters the press
secretary said and i quote
they can get boosted now regardless of
what cdc guidance is
whether you're just approved or for
booster or you've been approved for
weeks end quote
regardless of what cdc guidance is
from the white house podium
and then i was amazed when i got home on
sunday and i had this letter from
centers for medicare and medicaid
services
telling me as a medicare beneficiary
that
i'm eligible to get a free vaccine
booster
five months after the president
announced we're gonna have boosters
we're
this is the first communication from cms
that i've gotten as a medicare
beneficiary in the two years of covet
and all of a sudden i get a request to
get boosted
um
when a republican governor
or a former or a senator including
someone this committee suggests
concerns about cdc guidance twitter and
msnbc can't react fast enough with scorn
and anger
so it can't come as a surprise that
there is confusion and anger
when the white house says to ignore cdc
guidance
i tell my staff as i've repeatedly said
to you all in all previous hearings to
look 30 60 90 days ahead
look six and see what's happening in
asia europe israel africa uk and
elsewhere around the world
what do we need to anticipate in our
hearing on july 20th i warned that delta
would be would not be our last variant
and i plead it with each of you to have
a plan in place for the next mutation of
the virus
so why was the vice president surprised
that omnicron came to our shores
well i say it's very clear very clearly
so the administration does not yet again
say they're surprised viruses change
viruses mutate
there will be more variants they will
come to america period end of sentence
i don't understand why after tens of
billions of federal dollars
being appropriated this administration
has failed to ensure that the americans
have the tests they need
i don't understand why suddenly it's
okay to take into account the economic
and job impact of your guidance and
recommendations
you shorten quarantine guidance because
too many people would be out of work was
that because of science or was it
because
you now know
that lockdown shutdowns and school
closures
come with a significant
downside impact you ask the american
people to trust you
quite frankly you've lost their trust
rather than attempting to gain their
trust back the administration chooses to
litigate mandate requirements for
employers with over 100 employees
i've asked before what's the plan
never gotten a response
very seldom do i get a letter responded
to by this administration the
administration's not responding to my
letters maybe folks at the white house
don't think they need to respond to
republican senators
i think my record shows i'm approaching
all of this as i have for the last 20
years
i'm trying to help
i love this country love its people
and i know we can do better than we've
done
i know we have to do better
maybe i'm wrong about this maybe you'll
tell me where i got it wrong
instead
i'm hoping that you'll understand that
my criticism comes from a place of
concern
because the communication efforts are a
mess
and have only made things worse
now i admit it i'm at the end of my rope
i think you'll see today that most of my
colleagues are as well
i've tried to give my best advice and
share what we hear and what we see
because no one's paying attention to the
message from this administration right
now
maybe today you respond to my request to
learn what the plan is hopefully you'll
take this challenge to rebuild the trust
not just with me
not just with my colleagues
but with the american people we all
serve
what are you changing in fiction to
restore the confidence with the american
people that there is a strategy for
testing
for treatments for fixing your
communication strategy because if you
don't
things are going to get worse before
they get better
i'm chairman i yield back
thank you senator uh we will now
introduce today's witnesses
dr richelle olenski is the director of
the centers for disease control and
prevention and the administrator of the
agency for toxic substances and disease
registry
dr anthony fauci is the director of the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases and the chief
medical advisor on president biden's
coven 19 response team
dr janet woodcock is the acting
commissioner of the food and drug
administration
don o'connell is the assistant secretary
for preparedness and response
and director well wellensky director
fauci acting commissioner woodcock and
assistant secretary o'connell i want to
thank you all for joining us today we
all look forward to your testimony and
we will begin with dr wolinski on your
opening statement
good morning chair murray ranking member
burr members of the senate health
committee i appreciate the opportunity
to join you to provide an update on the
covet 19 pandemic and the impact of the
omicron variant
it has been just over two years since we
were first alerted to the emergence of
sars kovi ii in china and since that
time cdc has worked with our partner
agencies and you in congress to make
take remarkable action to protect the
health and safety of americans omicron
is now the dominant variant in the
united states driving case counts to
unprecedented heights here in the united
states and around the world
despite the increases in cases there are
promising emerging data from south
africa and the united kingdom that
hospitalization rates for people
infected with omicron are lower compared
with prior variants
these data seem consistent with what
we're seeing so far in the united states
however despite a potential decrease in
severity the substantial number of
absolute cases is resulting in
hospitalization increases across all age
groups including children age zero to
four
the emergence of the omicron variant
again emphasizes the importance of
vaccinations and boosters which decrease
the risk of infection severe disease and
death caused by covet 19.
just last week we made important
progress towards increasing booster
coverage through key four key actions
first we expanded eligibility of booster
doses to those 12 to 15 years old
second cdc strengthens its booster
recommendation for adolescents now
recommending that adolescents age 12 to
17 years old should receive a booster
shot five months after their initial
pfizer bioentec vaccine series
third we recommended that moderately or
severely immunocompromised five to 11
year olds receive an additional primary
dose of vaccine 28 days after their
second shot
and fourth we shortened the
recommendation between a primary mrna
series and a booster dose from six
months to five months
each action increases access to vaccines
and booster doses at a time when
protection
is critical
as we continue to monitor monitor this
rapidly evolving virus we are working
quickly to adapt with it
over the holidays cdc updated our
quarantine and isolation guidance first
for healthcare workers and then for the
general public
i know this update has resulted in
numerous questions so i would like to
take a moment to walk through it now
for people who tested positive for covet
19 cdc recommends isolation for five
days
if you are asymptomatic or if your
symptoms are resolving for example
you're without a fever for 24 hours you
no longer need to isolate
however you should continue to wear a
well-fitting mask at all times when
around others including at home and in
public for an additional five days
we recommend that you avoid activities
where you are unable to wear a mask and
that you avoid travel for the full 10
days
in addition cdc changed the recommended
duration of quarantine quarantine is
what you do after you're exposed
people who are not up to date on
recommended covet 19 vaccines
should quarantine for five days if they
come in contact with someone with covet
19.
people who do not develop symptoms by
day five should get tested if you test
positive you should begin isolation
people who test negative may end
quarantine and should continue to wear a
well-fitting bask when around others for
an additional five days
these recommendations are consistent
with over 100 studies collected over the
past two years
indicating that people are most
infectious during their first few days
of infection and significantly less
infectious six to ten days after
infection
a core part of cdc's mission is to
translate science into recommendations
for best practices and real world
circumstances
over the holidays we saw the growing
surge of omicron and took swift
science-based action to address the very
real possibility of staffing shortages
in hospitals and in other essential
areas of the workforce including schools
pharmacies public safety public labs
grocery stores and other sites where
shortages could have and have proven to
have dire public health consequences
this is the right guidance for what we
currently know about transmission and
the real world circumstances we
currently face
as we will learn more we will continue
to update accordingly
omicron is likely not to be the last
curveball this virus throws at us but we
have the tools to prevent further spread
of this virus
this means for everyone five and older
please get vaccinated for those 12 and
older get your booster shot and please
continue to adhere to the multi-layered
prevention measures including masking
and yes washing your hands thank you and
i look forward to your questions
thank you dr fauci
madam chair ranking member burr members
of the committee thank you for giving me
the opportunity to discuss with you the
role of the national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases in
the conduct and support
of research addressing our nation's
response to covert 19.
in our most recent hearing before this
committee on november the 4th
i discussed the importance of booster
shots to enhance immunity against a
delta variant that wanes over time
indeed booster shots have dramatically
reconstituted the waning immunity
and has increased protection over and
above the original level afforded
by the primary vaccine regimen
today
we are faced with a different challenge
a new variant called omicron that has
rapidly spread throughout the world
including a massive unprecedented surge
in the united states
this variant possesses a large number of
mutations
that are associated with an increased
efficiency of transmission
immune evasion from certain monoclonal
antibodies convalescent plasma
and antibodies induced by our current
vaccines
thus far
data from our own laboratories at niaid
as well as from laboratories throughout
the world have indicated
that vaccine-induced antibodies lose a
considerable amount of potency
in neutralizing the omnicom variant
although this is of obvious concern
the encouraging news is that a third
shock boost of an mrna vaccine
significantly reconstitutes
and enhances the ability of antibodies
from boosted individuals to neutralize
the omicron variant
strongly suggesting
that boosters will play a major role in
protecting our population at least from
severe disease
in the context
of the ongoing massive surge
of the omicron variant that we are
currently experiencing
underscoring why it is so important for
the unvaccinated to get vaccinated and
for those who are already vaccinated to
obtain the booster shot
therapies in general are an important
part of our armamentarium against covid
in this regard the nih has been heavily
involved
in the development and or clinical
testing
of several effective monoclonal
antibodies against saws kobe 2.
however
we have ascertained that certain of the
authorized monoclonal antibodies are
negatively impacted
by the omicron variant
direct antiviral therapies also are an
extremely important tool in the fight
against cover 19.
importantly
it appears that the mutations expressed
by the omicron variant do not interfere
with the oral antiviral drugs paxlovid
and malnupiravir
that nih-funded investigators played an
early role in developing
and that have recently received
emergency use authorization from the fda
nor do they appear to interfere
with the fda fully approved drug render
severe
shown by nih-sponsored studies
to be highly effective in preventing
severe disease
looking ahead in the context of the
inevitable continual emergence of new
variants
the importance of developing a panned
coronavirus vaccine namely one
that would be effective against all size
cov2 variants and ultimately against all
coronaviruses
becomes even more apparent
my colleagues and i
recently published a paper in the new
england journal of medicine
emphasizing the urgent need for such an
effort
in this regard
we have made significant progress in
that direction
we have identified antibodies that
neutralize multiple different
coronaviruses
and in addition
niaid has issued new awards to fund
panned coronavirus vaccines at four
academic institutions
these awards will fund
multi-disciplinary collaborative teams
to conduct research
focused on coronavirus virology and
immunology
image and design
and innovative vaccine and adjuvant
platforms
as well as technologies to discover
design and develop
panned coronavirus vaccine candidates
finally
i would like to close by looking forward
to how we might best enhance our
preparedness
for what inevitably will be the
emergence of future pandemics
the niaid will play an important role in
the multi-billion dollar
all-of-government plan
for pandemic pandemic preparedness
our mission
is the rapid development and
implementation of successful
countermeasures
against several prototype pathogen
families of viruses
that threaten the health and safety not
only of our nation
but of the entire world
thank you for your attention and i would
be happy to answer your questions
following the presentations
thank you dr woodcock
good morning chair murray ranking member
burr and members of the committee thank
you for the opportunity to testify
fda's thousands of employees remain
steadfast in fighting this pandemic our
work continued during the holiday season
and led to critical advancements in
combating the virus
the agency has been closely monitoring
the potential impact of the omicron
variant on the currently available
vaccines diagnostics and therapeutics
i'll provide a brief update and actions
the agency has taken
in these three areas since i last
testified before this committee
first regarding vaccines the currently
authorized and approved vaccines remain
highly effective at preventing serious
outcomes associated with covid19
infection including hospitalization and
death
additionally data evaluated by the fda
suggests that an additional booster shot
following the completion of primary
vaccination
provides further protection
against these outcomes
following these data fda updated the
pfizer bio and tech and moderna vaccine
euas to shorten the time between
completion of a primary series and a
booster dose to at least five months
rather than six months
fda also updated the pfizer bio and tech
eua so it's of now available for a
primary series in children five ages
five and older and for the use of a
booster dose in all individuals 12
through 15 years of age after completion
of primary vaccination as you've already
heard from dr olinsky
as the cdc followed up on this the
agency also authorized the pfizer
vaccine for a third primary series dose
for certain immunocompromised children
that are five through 11.
these vaccines have met fda's rigorous
standards and the bottom line is getting
vaccinated or receiving a booster with
one of the currently available vaccines
is the best thing the public can do
right now to protect themselves and
those they care about it is not too late
to get vaccinated or get boosted
second diagnostic tests which are
another key line of defense in this
pandemic
increasing
access to accurate rapid at-home tests
continues to be a priority for fda
since i last testified the agencies
authorized four additional
over-the-counter at home tests bringing
the total number to 15 and the agency
continues to prioritize a review of
these type of tests
we also partnered with the nih to
establish itap which streamlines
validation and author
authorization of antigen tests with
potential for large-scale manufacturing
we expect shorter review times for such
eua requests due to our partnership with
itap
in fact the first two tests that
participated in this program were
authorized in two days or less from the
time fda received the final data
so this is a very good model for
government assistance
of
diagnostic manufacturers
in this new program itap will prioritize
new over-the-counter test submissions it
could be manufactured at significant
scale
to accelerate the availability of high
quality accurate and reliable
tests for the public as quickly as
possible
third as new variants continue to emerge
it's crucial to expand the country's
arsenals of covid 19 therapeutics
especially for those unable to get
vaccinated or who can't respond to
vaccination
since i last testified three
therapeutics have been authorized for
use in the treatment of coven 19 for
emergency use
the first of these euas eview
shield was authorized for the prevention
of covid19
the other two therapies paxlavid and
molnapiravir as you heard from dr fauci
are the first authorized uh treatments
for covet 19 in the form of a pill that
can be taken orally which is a major
step in the fight against this global
pandemic
these authorizations provide new tools
to combat
covid19 at a crucial time
and it should make antiviral therapy
more accessible to people at high risk
for progression
now while these
are important tools they're not
substitute for vaccination
and people for whom vaccination is
recommended and i continue to urge the
public to get vaccinated if eligible
and fourth we continue our mission of
protecting the public from fraudulent
medical products
since march we've refused
admission of more than 23 thousand lines
of fda regulated products that we're
trying to get into the country illegally
and finally i wanna assure the public
that fda is committed to continue to use
every tool in our tool box to fight this
pandemic
with the best available diagnostics
life-saving therapeutics and vaccines
thank you and i look forward to your
questions
thank you assistant secretary o'connell
chair murray ranking member burr and
distinguished members of the committee
it is an honor to testify you before you
today on efforts within asper to respond
to the pandemic since the emergence of
the omicron variant
when omicron first emerged as we have
done with each new variant we
immediately evaluated its impact on our
current vaccines therapy
adjusted our response accordingly
data suggests that our current vaccine
doses with a boost confer protection
against omicron as a result we have
continued distributing the three
authorized and approved vaccines
over 600 million doses of vaccine have
been developed and delivered since the
start of the pandemic
we have ample supply of both primary and
booster doses
contributing to more than 200 million
americans now being fully vaccinated
however we have had to make adjustments
to our therapeutic supply in light of
omicron
two of our workhorse monoclonal
therapies one from lily the other from
regeneron are not as effective against
omicron as a result we have increased
our supply of gsk's monoclonal which is
effective
we continue to purchase all that we can
from gsk
though this supply is still limited we
are on track to have
courses available this month
a fourth monoclonal by astrazeneca is
targeted for immunocompromised
individuals
at high risk and is taken prior to
exposure to prevent infection
it has retained effectiveness against
omicron and we will have made nearly
half a million courses available through
the end of this month
all four monoclonals are currently
available for states and jurisdictions
to order free of charge on a weekly
basis to treat either omicron or delta
infections
also
we now have antivirals by pfizer and
merck that are effective against omicron
and are being delivered to states free
of charge every other week
we have procured 3.1 million courses of
merck that are now available
last week we doubled our commitment to
order 20 million courses of pfizer's
product
we have
265 000 courses available through this
month and anticipate delivering the
first 10 million courses to states by
mid-summer
we remain in frequent communication with
states and territorial health officials
on the distribution of therapeutic
products and continue to focus on
ensuring
these life-saving therapies are
available to americans across the
country
the dramatic rise in cases due to
omicron has put a significant strain on
our testing capacity despite significant
effort and investment there's more work
to do and we are working every day and
night with manufacturers to increase the
availability of tests
as soon as we saw the dramatic increase
in cases in south africa and europe we
reached out to test manufacturers to
understand their surge capacity and
supply chain constraints we are engaging
daily with the lab test providers to
mitigate any supply chain constraints
with their sub-tier suppliers
we are also working with the commercial
and public health labs to prioritize
their needs we continue to use the
defense production acts authorities when
needed
to further increase test availability we
are procuring 500 million rapid tests to
distribute to american households
as a requirement in this procurement
none of these tests can interfere with
what is available in the current
commercial market so as not to diminish
what consumers are able to access now
we are currently shipping 2.8 million
tests to long-term care facilities per
week as we have throughout the pandemic
we continue to work to send 50 million
rapid tests to federally qualified
health centers and food banks with 7
million having shipped so far
and we will keep working around the
clock with manufacturers and our
government partners to increase and
sustain the number of tests available
now and in the future and finally in
addition to vaccines therapeutics and
testing asper continues to provide
on-the-ground support to states and
communities in need since july 40
national disaster medical system teams
nearly 880 team members have deployed to
19 separate states and the commonwealth
of the northern mariana islands to
support a range of functions including
hospital augmentation and decompression
setting up medical overflow centers for
patients and mortuary support
we continue to send supplies as
requested from the strategic national
stockpile including 300 ventilators to
six jurisdictions since the emergence of
omicron
we are grateful for the support from
this committee in congress and i look
forward to answering your questions
thank you to all of our witnesses we
will now begin a round of five-minute
questions of our witnesses and i again
ask my colleagues to keep track of your
clock and stay within those five minutes
as the omicron variant of coven 19
continues to spread at an alarming rate
people are looking for clear
straightforward guidance on how to
protect themselves and those around them
it is really critical that we reduce the
infection rates so we can relieve
pressure on our health care workers
protect people with disabilities and
older americans young kids and anyone
else who's been disproportionately
impacted by coven 19. however i have
heard from so many people who find the
latest cdc isolation and quarantine
guidance confusing and hard to interpret
so dr wolinski can you please clearly
explain cdc's latest guidance on what
people need to do to protect themselves
and others if they are exposed to or
contract covet 19 and let me start with
vaccinated people what is your guidance
to them
thank you to murray for the opportunity
to clarify maybe if i could just rewind
the clock to just before the holidays
where we were hearing from hospitals
that they were their staff were going
out and that they were in a real crunch
in terms of beds they had plenty of beds
but they didn't have staff to
to staff them
icu beds were starting to close so
immediately we worked towards our
updated healthcare worker guidance but
when we did so we recognized that we
were going to have challenges and that
this omicron surge that we were about to
face was threatening many other places
of our health care sector i appreciate
the background but i just want to know
straightforward if someone is exposed to
or has coven 19 and they're vaccinated
what do they do if they are
exposed to covet 19 and they are
completely boosted they should they do
not need to stay home um but they should
get a test at day five if they have
covered our
guidance is not does not distinguish
between your vaccination status and our
science has demonstrated that you're
maximally infectious two days before and
two to three days after so by five days
after your symptoms if you're feeling
better if your fever is better if your
cough and sore throat are better then on
day six you can go out but you have to
wear a mask you have to wear a mask
reliably and you should not go to places
you can't wear a mask you probably
shouldn't go and visit grandma you
shouldn't get on an airplane for
vaccinated what about unvaccinated same
for unvaccinated for isolation so
isolation being those who have had
disease who have disease
okay
well let me just say nearly two years
ago when this committee first started
having congressional hearings on coven
19 the very first thing i asked was
where are the tests
and we've made progress since then and
we're now producing 300 million rapid
at-home tests each month along with
ramping up our lab-based testing but i
am disappointed as i said by the testing
challenges that we're facing uh tests
are hard to find they're costly people
are unable to find the at-home tests in
pharmacies online uh we're they're
waiting in long lines um and often after
that waiting days for results so it's
you know ineffective
at the end of the day so miss o'connell
i want to ask you what are you doing to
address the frustrations and challenges
we are hearing about covet testing
chair murray thank you so much for this
very important question testing remains
a critical priority for this
administration
when we saw the unprecedented cases of
omicron sweep into south africa and
europe we immediately reached out to our
manufacturers to understand any supply
constraints they had and to evaluate
their surge capacity
we have also met daily with them to make
sure that they have what they need
from their suppliers and have used the
defense production act authorities 12
times throughout this pandemic in
support
of testing needs most recently in the
last few weeks for two tests
we were able to unlock supplies and
manufacturing capacity
we continue to invest in
rapid over-the-counter tests which are
in high demand and in the fall we
invested three billion dollars uh to
increase manufacturing line staffing and
to commit to those manufacturing lines
for 13 months
as a result we went from 50 46 million
test
over-the-counter tests available in
october to the 300 million jeremy that
you just uh mentioned that are available
now
but that's not enough we're continuing
to
bring tests to the american people as a
result the president has announced and
we are in the process of procuring the
500 million tests which every american
household will be able to order and have
shipped directly to their house
we have completed four contracts so far
uh have secured 50 million tests and are
in the process of securing the
additional tests over the next uh
several days the u.s postal service has
agreed to do the distribution
and the u.s
digital services is going to help with
the website
we anticipate the first test going out
at the end of this month with the
remaining tests going out over the next
60 days okay and i'm out of time but i
do want to just say this i am hearing
from so many schools that are having
trouble staying open they want to stay
open part of it is they have staff that
are sick that's understandable but a big
part of it is they don't have access to
the safety measures like masks and
uh and and testing supplies what do i
tell them about where they go to get
that
chair murray thank you have a schools
having enough supply uh testing supplies
to stay open is a critical priority
for us we've invested 10 billion dollars
of the american rescue plan uh
given to states to support and stand up
testing programs we've also invested
sixty six hundred and fifty million
dollars in a program called operation
expanded testing which set up regional
hubs of labs that schools could contract
with to run their testing programs but
that doesn't work if there aren't tests
available so asper is working directly
with states to match additional
manufacturing capacity with states that
need it not only that we are in the
process within asper of looking at our
contracts to see if we have any
additional capacity and will commit to
sending that capacity to the school
programs
senator
burke thank you madam chairman
let me just cut to the chase
dr fauci
you said cdc was going to update its
guidance and include antigen testing or
suggested that it would dr
wolinski and cdc came out with the
guidance that didn't include it
was that part of the communications plan
to start with and they diverted or was
that something you just chose to inject
thank you for that question senator burr
in discussions about the real gray zone
uh which
dr wolinski described about after the
five days where you have a considerable
diminution in the likelihood of being
transmitting we had been in discussions
about what the role of antigen testing
would be
and as a matter of fact when dr walensky
came out with the final guidelines they
include
that if you are a test available you may
take a test so at the end of the day we
were quite in concordance with our views
well i i think the chair and i share
this we found it very confusing
and i think the american people found it
confusing and i don't say it lightly
when i say
not too many people in america are
listening to what comes out of
washington whether it's congress or out
of the administration as it relates to
covid
so the president makes an announcement
ms mcconnell 500 million at home test
is this the first time that you've
thought about purchasing an at-home test
or have you tried to before and it was
rejected
thank you ranking member um
this is the first time the
administration has committed to
purchasing uh
tests to send to the american households
so is that asper or is that dod
because of all the notifications of
contracts signed
i've seen them from dod i haven't seen
them from hhs
thank you for that question ranking
member we use uh we have a relationship
with dod for assisted acquisitions so
asper will request that dod uh put out a
solicitation or manage a contract on our
behalf uh they're able to do it
extraordinarily quickly and we've had an
mou in place with dod for this work uh
that will run through uh june 2023 we've
used this relationship to purchase
vaccines and therapeutics and we're now
using it for testing so
the best i can find you mentioned 50
million doses having been contracted i
can identify 27 million out of two
companies media
and
atlantic
trading
neither one of them are manufacturers of
test and i believe the third one revival
is not a manufacturer of test
media actually came to fame was
importation of vodka and tying cell
phones to vodka and like a lot of other
companies they got in the ppe business
in 2020 with some nominal fema contracts
why should we have any confidence in
these contracts
if in fact we're dealing with companies
that don't manufacture anything and can
you assure me that the tests that
are coming in are not coming from china
thank you uh ranking member absolutely
these tests uh what we initially did to
be able to
access uh tests for the initial
shipments that will go uh towards the
end of january we worked with warehouses
to see where additional tests were
stored
and assessed that additional capacity
and are bringing that capacity to bear
for these initial tests that are going
out which is why you're seeing contracts
with warehouses and not with test
manufacturers
so is what you're telling me they've got
50 million tests in warehouses in the
united states and all we did was access
that that
inventory
that is my understanding well
will you confirm your understanding this
this is a very very important piece
when you've got companies that don't
manufacture tests and all of a sudden
we're giving them 190 million dollar
contract for about 14 million
home tests
and their expertise is importation of
vodka
i encourage you to look through the list
of people that we're signing up with
are you aware that
some of the larger test manufacturers in
2021
shut down lines because the lack
of purchases for at home test
one of the things we did in the fall
with the three billion dollar investment
that we made was to turn lines on and to
commit to those lines for 13 months so
they wouldn't be turned off again
dr woodcock let me just the last
question uh chair um
of the 15 tests that you've currently
approved for over-the-counter how many
detect omnicron
we're still working on that but we
believe all of them detect omnicron we
simply feel they are somewhat less
sensitive than they were to some of the
previous variants of the 50 million
tests that the asper has contracted for
how many of those tests detect omnicron
i don't know which tests there are we
can get back to you on that so you
haven't consulted with what we're
purchasing on the 500 million they
haven't consulted with fda to figure out
whether the tests they're buying
actually detect omnicron i believe they
have i simply don't have that list okay
i thank the chair
senator kaine
thank you chair marine to the witnesses
dr fauci can you provide us a general
breakdown of what percentage of
hospitalized individuals are vaccinated
versus unvaccinated and what percentage
of covet deaths are among vaccinated or
unvaccinated individuals
thank you for that question senator kane
one of the ways
to answer that question be to look at
people who are in the hospital and take
a look at if you are vaccinated versus
unvaccinated and if you look at
vaccinated versus unvaccinated there's
about a 10 times greater chance that
you'd be infected if you were
unvaccinated about a 17 times greater
chance that you'd be hospitalized if you
were unvaccinated and about a 20 times
likelihood that you would be that that
you would be
dead if you were unvaccinated so when
you look at every parameter 10 times 17
times 20 times infection hospitalization
death
thank you dr fauci um
ms o'connell i want to ask you a
question about vaccine additional
vaccine development
um the current vaccines against covet
as was indicated by dr fauci's answer
have been very successful in reducing
deaths
severity of illnesses and hospital
admissions however they've had more
limited success in preventing forward
transmission from vaccinated individuals
after breakthrough cases
and the existing vaccines are not as
durable as vaccines in other
areas so we need booster shots to
continue to
protect against the virus
is the administration considering
supporting the development of additional
vaccines that might be able to address
the gaps in the current vaccine's
capabilities
senator kaine thank you so much for that
question yes absolutely i think we all
see the need for next generation
vaccines we are also looking for next
generation antivirals and therapeutics
as well we're in the process of working
with dr fauci's team to develop a
unified nih barda
research agenda
and budget to address these issues to
identify candidates that might already
be in the pipeline
to help support the research into
candidates that are just starting in the
pipeline
to so we can accelerate
the availability of next generation
vaccines and therapeutics
thank you for that answer dr wolinski
i'd like to ask you a question about
access to testing
and in particular
what is the cdc doing to make sure that
testing capacity is robust in rural
america and also
among community health centers in
in disadvantaged parts of the country
thank you senator kaine so we have this
program increased community access to
testing in collaboration with uh with
asper as well
this is a program that has um
collaborated with fema to increase surge
testing just over the holidays we've
increased uh testing federal testing
sites for pcrs 12 federal testing sites
doing thousands of tests over the
holiday we also work with pharmacies
this is a collaboration with pharmacies
um and in that instead we are able to
map where the pharmacies are and their
social vulnerability index and we can
actually put pcr tests in areas of high
social vulnerability index through all
of our pharmacy partners cvs walgreens
rite aid and whatnot
and then we actually put tests in our
community centers as well so really a
broad stretch in our in order to be able
to get access to testing especially
among those most vulnerable and then of
course as asper o'connell mentioned 10
billion dollars for testing supplies um
to our schools and working closely with
our schools in peer-to-peer support in
techno technical support to allow those
tests to be used um well in those school
settings thank you thank you for that
answer and dr fauci one more question
for you i ask a version of this question
every time we have this panel before us
what is the nih doing right now or
what's the current status of nih
research to better understand long covid
to look at
symptoms and potential treatments
there are several
uh levels of activity going on
some news since we spoke last i had
mentioned to you senator
that in fact there was a 1.15 billion
program
for studying long covid that is now
developing cohorts to look at various
incidences prevalences pathogenesis and
potential interventions
there have been a number of awards that
have been given
most recently in september there was an
additional 470 million dollar funding
supported through the american rescue
plan
engaging about 100 researchers from 30
institutions to get individuals together
one of the things that's
really interesting that we're seeing
right now
is that when you look at individuals who
have these symptoms that go on as you
know and have experienced yourself
for a considerable period of time
a recent study that is
in the pre-print stage
so it hasn't been peer reviewed
has some very interesting information
that needs to be validated and verified
it was an autopsy study in people who
had varying levels of covet from
relatively mildly symptomatic to
moderately symptomatic individuals who
actually died
and when they looked
at the spread of what was not
necessarily replication competent virus
but was pc horrible virus which means
you could have nucleotides that were
there
there was a seems to be a persistence in
multiple organ systems indicating that
even if you clear the virus one of the
possibilities and i have to emphasize
possibility because it needs to be
validated
is that you don't completely clear the
fragments of the virus and you have
continual stimulation not that you're
infectious or that you're going to
infect anybody else but that it is still
generating perhaps an aberrant response
in your immune system i underscore again
it's preliminary it's in the pre-print
stage and it needs to be peer-reviewed
but that's some of the information we're
starting to gather thank you very much
for that answer thank you chairman
senator paul
dr falchi
the idea that a government official like
yourself would claim
unilaterally to represent science
that any criticism of you would be
considered a criticism of science itself
is quite dangerous
central planning whether it be of the
economy or of science is risky because
of the fallibility of the planner it
would not be so catastrophic if the
planner were simply one physician in
peoria
then the mistakes would only affect that
physician's patients the people who
chose that physician
but when the planner is a government
official like yourself who rules by
mandate the errors are compounded and
become much more harmful
a planner who believes he is the science
leads to an arrogance that justifies in
his mind using government resources to
smear
and to destroy the reputations of other
scientists who disagree with them in an
email exchange with dr collins you
conspire and i quote here directly from
the email
to create a quick and devastating
published takedown of three prominent
epidemiologists from harvard
oxford and stanford apparently there's a
lot of fringe epidemiologists at harvard
oxford and stanford and you quote in the
email that they or from dr collins and
you you agree that they are fringe
immediately there's this takedown effort
a published takedown though you know
doesn't exactly conjure up the image of
a dispassionate scientist
instead of engaging them on the merits
even dr collins sought to smear them as
fringe and take them down
and not in journals in lay press
this is not only antithetical to the
scientific method it's the epitome of
cheap politics and it's reprehensible dr
faucie do you really think it's
appropriate to use your 420 000 salary
to attack scientists that disagree with
you
the email you're referring to was an
email of dr collins to me if you look at
the email that you responded to and
hurried up and said i can do it i can do
it we got something in wired oh no i
think in usual fashion
senator you are distorting everything
about me did you ever object to dr
collins's characterization of them as
friends did you write back to dr collins
say no they're not fringe they're
esteemed scientists and it would be
beneath me i did not do that you
responded to him that you would do it
and you immediately got an article in
wired and you sent it back to him said
hey look i've got them i nailed them in
wired of all sides that's not what went
on there you go again just do the same
thing every year that was your response
and this was this wasn't the only time
so your desire to take down people and
correct as usual senator you incorrect
almost everything well no you deny you
deny but the emails tell the truth of
this no this wasn't the only time your
desire to take down those who disagree
with you didn't stop with harvard oxford
and stanford you conspired with peter
dazak who you communicated with
privately and other members of the
scientific community that wrote opinion
pieces for nature five of them signed a
paper for nature an opinion piece 17
signed a paper that called it conspiracy
theory the idea that the virus could
have originated in the lab do you think
words like conspiracy theory should be
in a scientific paper
senator i never used that word when i
was referring to it you're distorting
virtually everything did you communicate
with the five scientists who wrote the
opinion piece in nature where they were
describing oh this there's no way this
could have come from what's on the lab
me what i did you talk with any of those
scientists but keep the you keep
deciding the truth it is you talk you
talk to any of the scientists privately
yes you wrote the opinion you did what
were they telling you privately well let
me explain you know you're going back to
that original discussion when i brought
together
a group of people to look at every
possibility with an open mind so you not
only are you distorting it you will
completely turning it around as well
scientists that came to you privately
did they come to you privately and say
no way this came from the lab or was
there an initial impression dr gary and
others that were involved was there an
initial impression actually that it
looked very suspicious for a virus who
came from a lab
senator we are here
at a committee
to look at a virus now that has killed
almost 900 000 people and the purpose of
the committee was to try and get things
out how we can help to get the american
public and you keep coming back to
personal attacks on me that have
absolutely no relevance to reality do
you think anybody has had more influence
let me finish this than you have do you
manage
do you think it's a great success what's
happening so far do you think you're
locked in good for our kids do you think
we slowed down the death rate more
people have died now under president
biden did under president trump you are
the one responsible you are the
architect you are the lead architect for
the response from the government and now
800 000 people have died right do you
think it's a winning success what you've
advocated for government
um senator first of all
if you look at everything that i said
you accuse me of in a monolithic way
telling people what they need to do
everything that i've said
has been in support of the cdc
guidelines
wear a mask get boosted and you've added
that to make it courses
everything
could be done by mandate but you've
advocated that your infallible opinion
be dictated by law right so again madam
chair i would like just a couple of
minutes because this
this happens all the time you personally
attack me
and with absolutely not a shred of
evidence of anything you say so i would
like to make something clear to the
committee he's doing this for political
reasons what you need to do is he said
in front of this committee do you think
your take down i was prominent
epidemiologist was not political you
don't want me to finish you know what
i'm going to say that was the question
political and taking down these three
prominent
epidemiological paul if you would please
um i'm going to allow this uh dr fatchi
to respond we have a number of senators
who would like to ask questions and i
would like him to be able to respond
please do so
the last time we had a committee of the
time before he was accusing me of being
responsible for the death of five four
to five million people
which is really irresponsible and i say
why is he doing that there are two
reasons why that's really bad
the first is it distracts from what
we're all trying to do here today
is get our arms around
the epidemic and the pandemic that we're
dealing with
not something imaginary number two
what happens when he gets out
and accuses me of things that are
completely untrue
is that all of a sudden that kindles the
crazies out there and i have life that
threats upon my life
harassment of my family
and my children without seeing phone
calls
because people are lying about me
now you know i guess you could say well
that's the way it goes i can take the
hit
well it it makes a difference because as
some of you may know
just about three or four weeks ago on
december 21st
a person was arrested
who was on their way from sacramento to
washington dc
at a speed stop in iowa
and they asked the police asked him
where he was going
and he was going to washington dc
to kill dr fauci and they found in his
car an ar-15
and multiple magazines of ammunition
because he thinks that maybe i'm killing
people so i ask myself
why would senator want to do this
so go to
rand paul website
and you see
fire dr fauci with a little box that
says contribute here you can do dollars
ten dollars twenty dollars a hundred
dollars so you are making a catastrophic
epidemic for your political gain so the
owners have politically attacked your
colleagues and in a politically
reprehensible the only thing that like
the reputation okay he won't defend it
no don't argue it i'm just simply turn
around continue this hearing we have a
number of questions after another one
one more minute please dr katy i i
really appreciate your response but we
do have a number of questions from
senators and we do have a second round
and i'm being asked to make sure that
everybody has their time so thank you
thank you very much for allowing me
madam chair
uh we will move to senator murphy
thank you madam chair dr fauci thank you
thank you first of all for what you do
you shouldn't have to put your life at
risk
you shouldn't have to put your family's
life at risk to simply
stand up and do your job to try to
protect my constituents from a pandemic
disease
and thank you for calling out this
agenda for what it is
an attempt to score political points to
build a political power base
around the denial of science and around
personal attacks on you and your family
on social media i follow many of
president
trump's advisors and family members and
they make a sport
out of attacking you personally some of
the most vicious hateful ugly ways that
are possible they do it because it gets
clicks
they don't do it because they're
legitimately engaged
in a honest debate about the science
revolving surrounding covid
those people attack you because
it
gains them political followers
and so i appreciate the fact that you're
willing to stand up for yourself and for
your colleagues
who have been dragged into the political
muck
not because
those that follow president trump are
interested in a
honest science-based debate about how to
attack covet but because they see
political opportunity
um so thank you
dr fauci for your work for the panel's
work and for sticking up for yourself
which is not always easy
um
doctor willing scout wanna take
my time to just do a little bit of a
of an update on best practices for
schools um i know we talk about this a
lot here but um you know part of what i
think is um
frustrating for a lot of parents is
um that the guidance they're getting
from their schools changes and i get it
educators are sort of adjusting as the
variant changes as technology changes
but um
what um what has changed since the last
time has anything changed since the last
time you were here about what you were
recommending for schools to stay open i
appreciate what you said in the last
hearing is that schools should be the
first places to open and the last places
to close man as the parent of two
public school kids um i couldn't agree
more the trauma on these kids um during
this pandemic has been significant and
the data tells us that especially for
poor kids and kids of color distance
learning just doesn't work
um so i i'm grateful that i've got a
governor who's gone to extraordinary
lengths to make sure that the federal
dollars are used to keep schools open
but anything new that you can share with
us about what you're recommending for
schools to stay open for the rest of the
year
thank you senator murphy and in fact you
took the words right out of my mouth
school should be the first places to
open and the last places to close we had
a delta surge in the fall and 99 percent
of our schools were safely opened and
one of the things that's majorly
different between september of 2021 and
today is we have pediatric vaccinations
we have vaccines that are available for
every child over the age of five and the
children who are in the hospital now are
largely those who are unvaccinated so
first and foremost one of the most
important things that's changed is we
should be getting our children and our
teenagers vaccinated and if our
teenagers are eligible we have boosters
available for our teenagers as well so
we saw through the delta surge that we
were able to keep our children safely in
school before we had vaccines so now
today what do we have for our children
we have vaccines of course that we can
use we have school testing programs we
have new science that demonstrates tests
to stay this is where a child might be
exposed in the classroom but if they're
exposed they don't have to stay home in
quarantine they can test every other day
or twice a week and stay in the
classroom safely and what that has
demonstrated is hundreds of thousands of
person days of children in school rather
than at home we have new science that
has demonstrated the value of masking
three and a half times increased risk of
school outbreaks if you're masking in if
you're unmasked in schools versus if
you're masking in schools and just this
week we updated our k-12 guidance so
that it's consistent with our isolation
and quarantine guidance for the general
public so that people can come back to
school after isolation after five days
uh thank you uh dr olenski for uh for
that and for your commitment to keeping
our schools open final quick question
for you
ms o'connell um
talking about in-home tests obviously a
lot of focus on in-home tests today but
these are antigen tests there are some
uh you know interesting research going
on about the ability to make pcr tests
available at home and there's
companies all over the country including
one in connecticut that you know believe
that with some additional investment to
bring those tests to scale we could get
pcr tests
into families hands at home for a cost
that is at or below what we're currently
charging or companies are currently
charging for antigen tests is that a
possibility
senator murphy thank you we share your
interest of course in seeing as many
tests available for the american people
as quickly as possible
and at barda have worked very closely
with several of the manufacturers that
you mentioned for these at home pcr
tests uh we've contracted uh with one of
them and have reached 5 million per
month manufacturing capacity in contract
with them and continue to look at the
others in ways that we can support them
i would also like to say nih colleagues
in a program called rad x the rapid
acceleration of diagnostics are working
very closely with many of these
companies as well as they go through the
development stages so we remain very
committed uh to the work that these
companies are doing and uh look forward
to partnering with them as they begin to
bring these products forward
thank you senator collins
thank you very good
ms o'connell
over the past two years congress has
appropriated
82.6 billion dollars
specifically for testing in addition
we've given the department flexibility
to use other sources of funding and yet
as you've heard repeatedly today our
frustrated constituents cannot find
rapid tests when they need them
this testing crisis appears to have been
entirely preventable
as is evidenced by the availability the
widespread availability
of rapid tests in europe for example
the fact is that it appears the
administration simply failed to
anticipate
our testing needs as the former
assistant secretary of health recently
pointed out a lack of federal orders for
tests between january and september of
2021
caused the manufacturers to reduce their
lines and lay workers up including at
abbott facilities in the state of maine
where 400 workers were laid off
as a member of the appropriations
committee i share the concerns that have
been expressed by senators burr and
blunt i don't believe that we're in the
position that we are in now
due to a lack of funding but rather a
lack of planning
my question to you
is has any of this funding this close to
83 billion dollars that was supposed to
be used for testing
been diverted for other purposes
senator collins thank you for this
question testing remains a priority for
this administration and all the work
we've done on testing has been uh
to to to promote the priorities of
expanding the number of testing sites
available
expanding the type of tests that are
available for use in the united states
expanding the supply of tests in the
united states and lowering the cost of
tests um and we use 47 billion dollars
that came in the american rescue plan 10
billion of that went to schools you know
through the states to set up the school
testing programs 8.3 billion has gone to
community
testing sites including for the
uninsured and at the community health
centers the pharmacy program dr walinsky
mentioned
5 billion has gone to procure
tests and supplies and an additional 4.5
billion will go towards this 500 million
that we are in the process of procuring
29 billion has gone directly to states
from previous supplementals for them to
build and promote testing programs
within their jurisdictions the testing
money as you recall was for testing
contact tracing and mitigation
efforts and some of that of the funds
have been used um for
mitigation efforts uh for example when
uh
children are crossing the border you
know one of the responsibilities that we
have within hhs is to make sure uh that
anyone who is
that that the children that are
unaccompanied are cared for
and we used some of the funds to test
those children and then to separate them
from covet negative children at the
border was i'm going to repeat my
question because you did not answer it
has any of that money been used
for
non-testing
related purposes
at the border
for the mitigation purposes as well
which the
legislation allowed the funding to be
used for
i will follow up with you because i
don't feel like i'm getting an answer
uh dr falchi
just last week the president once again
said that covet 19 is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
and let me make very clear that i've
encouraged vaccinations
i believe in them
but contracting
contradicting the president's statement
in maine our largest health system
reported
that absences of vaccinated staff
caused by covet 19 last week
was at the highest point
since vaccines became available it's
increased by four-fold
does the message that covet
is a pandemic of the unvaccinated still
hold true
with the emergence of omicron and do you
agree with the new york times
which has twice reported that while the
covet vaccine is critical
in preventing hospitalizations and death
it is less effective against the omicron
variant
thank you for that question senator
yes indeed it is there's no doubt
that the omicron variant when you look
at the protection
against symptomatic disease and
asymptomatic infection dramatically goes
down
to about 30 percent
what maintains itself
it goes up to about
70 it's about 70 percent against severe
disease when you boost when you boost
what happens is you get a rather
significant reconstitution
of the protection particularly against
hospitalization
so if you were to say
that omicron or even covet 19 as it is
is really a pandemic when you're talking
about pandemic that causes serious
disease
there's no doubt that there's an
extraordinary
divergence
of risk between a vaccinated and an
unvaccinated person in response
to the question just a bit ago when i
said that if you look at vaccinated
versus unvaccinated there's a 17 times
greater chance of being hospitalized
than a 20 times greater chance of dying
if you are unvaccinated versus
vaccinated
thank you um senator hassan
thank you madam chair and
ranking member bern thank you to all of
our witnesses for being here today and
for your ongoing work i
deeply appreciate it dr fauci i want to
start with a couple of questions for you
we need to make sure that individuals
who become seriously ill with covet 19
can receive treatment and that doctors
have clear guidelines on the
effectiveness of each treatment
for the latest variant and you touched
on this in your opening statement but i
would like you to just expand a little
bit on this in light of omicron how is
the administration evaluating new coven
19 treatments and monitoring the
effectiveness of existing treatments
thank you for that question senator
there are a number of studies
that have been conducted
and that are being
conducted right now and they have to do
with studies that are nih-sponsored one
of which is the adaptive
covert 19 treatment trials
or act act which in fact
have been from the very beginning as
early as february of 2020
was the basis for the fda approval
of the antiviral remdessevier
other of those studies
particularly those on monoclonal
antibodies
showed several of them in the clinical
trials
to be effective
at first against delta we know now that
a couple of them
except for one
has now lost some of its effectiveness
there's another group of studies
called active and there are six of those
and that stands for accelerating covert
19 therapeutic interventions and
vaccines and the whole gamut
of oral iv
monoclonal antibodies direct antivirals
and as i mentioned in my opening
statement
viral antivirals like have pak slovad
and mao nu piravir the original research
had been done in the early trials
by the nih but importantly in direct
answer to
how we know what to use
the nih has put together a guidelines
panel made up of 48 highly qualified
clinicians and individuals with
experience in covert 19
to give a prioritization
of what you do if you are infected and
with advanced disease in the hospital
as well as what you do as an outpatient
and they're fairly clearly delineated
in the guidelines which is easily
accessible by just going to the nih
website
and going to nih.gov and then guidelines
panel
and people can get a good idea
clinicians throughout the country in the
world
of how to use these antivirals thank you
thank you
i want to follow up i am grateful that
the administration heeded my call to
send fema teams to new hampshire to help
administer covet 19 treatments however
the teams were delayed in arriving and
are scheduled to stay only for a short
period of time so dr fauci what
additional personnel and support is the
administration planning to provide to
new hampshire and other states to help
treat covet 19 patients in the most
effective way possible
well
there are several things perhaps
uh assistant secretary of ghana can
answer but i can start off by saying
that there are surge teams right now at
least 60 search teams
that have been deployed to help those
areas
that have difficulty because of the
surge and the fewer volume of cases to
be able to handle them with regard to
everything from hospitalizations to
treatment and other implementations
and and i appreciate that
assistant secretary o'connell is in a
good position to follow up and i would
like to follow up after the hearing but
i did want to ask one other question uh
to dr polinski um
we've long had problems with accurate
state vaccination data in new hampshire
it's come to light that the cdc's data
on new hampshire's vaccination rates is
also inaccurate apparently the cdc can't
consistently distinguish in its data
between first doses of the vaccine and
boosters and as a result the agency
incorrectly records boosters as first
doses artificially raising the
vaccination rate
the cdc's data is inaccurate for other
states as well we've been looking at
this
for for other states too so what steps
is the cdc taking to resolve these data
inaccuracies and when will the cdc have
accurate data for new hampshire
thank you senator this is a really
important question so cdc is the
compiler of the data and we rely on the
state immunization
services to
provide cdc the data at the state level
now among the challenges with these
accuracies is that if people don't bring
in their card
they are counted as a first dose when in
fact their card would have been a third
dose and we rely on the states to work
to reconcile any differences if a person
put in a minimal initial on one cart but
not on another and we're working closely
with every single state to increase the
accuracy we're encouraging people to
bring their cards because that also
increases the accuracy we recognize this
challenge and we are working state by
state including in new hampshire to
reconcile these inaccuracies to get them
more accurate in our comprehensive
reporting of every state well i i
appreciate that very much thank you
madam chair i'll just say that uh what
i'm hearing you say
to the general public is it's really
important to help uh with the accuracy
of data by keeping your car taking a
photo of your card making sure that
you're sharing all your information
at the site where you're getting a
vaccine or booster shot very helpful yes
thank you very much thank you thank you
senator marshall
president biden inherited a vaccine a
distribution plan trillions of dollars
in funding
but unfortunate administrations chose to
put all its eggs in one basket
prioritized unconstitutional vaccine
mandates and testing
yet comparing 2021 to 2022
covet infections have increased 72
percent and deaths increased 27
this we know if you look at this data
your current plan is not working
the current plan is not working we need
therapeutics at warp speed
miss o'connell who is responsible for
this failure
senator marshall thank you for that
question
we are making six therapies available uh
to the american people free of charge
who's responsible for the failure
senator marshall we continue to make
therapies available at warp speed to the
american people the bite administration
has allocated over eighty billion
dollars for testing and only fifteen
billion dollars on therapeutics
it's obvious that your plan has failed
we can't keep throwing good money after
bad money this is insanity
we have to admit our mistakes and go a
different direction
miss mcconnell
would you commit to an operation warp
speed for therapeutics
senator marshall thank you therapeutics
are part of operation warp speed and
that's how we have the six therapies
that we're currently making available to
states free of charge they'll be
available after delta is is already
been come and gone and also after of
course omicron will be said and done as
well dr fauci
59 percent of americans and 81 percent
of republicans do not have a favorable
opinion of you
frankly honestly you've lost your
reputation
the american people don't trust the
words coming out of your mouth
every day you appear on tv you do more
damage than good when it comes to
educating the public on coven
suppose you were leading a team in an
effort to try to get people to stop
smoking cigarettes
but every time your spokesperson goes on
television over half the nation goes out
and buys a pack of marlboros
wouldn't you stop that person from
appearing on national television
once again senator marshall i believe
that's a real distortion of the reality
if you look at everything
that i've said
on tv
it is to
validate
encourage
and get people to abide by the
recommendations of the centers for
disease control and prevention look at
everything i've ever said yeah dr
patrick has vaccinated but perception is
reality yeah and you're hurting the team
right now you are hurting the team right
now dr fauci you previously told this
committee under oath that nih and naid
have never funded gain of function
research with the eco health alliance
however report from the department of
defense inspector general released
yesterday states that eco health
alliance approached darpa in 2018
seeking funding to conduct gain of
function research on bat born
coronaviruses
this proposal named project defuse def
usc was rejected by darpa because the
project didn't address the current
researcher's potential to violate the
gain of function moratorium the proposal
does not mention or assess potential
risk of gain of function research that's
a direct quote from the darpa rejection
letter
the same proposal rejected by darpa for
gain of function
potential was not rejected but by nia
iaid under your leadership you funded
project diffuse and its research that
took place at the wuhan institute of
virology
why did you tell the committee that your
agency has never funded gain of function
research why did your agency award this
grant despite it being rejected by darpa
due to its concerns about violating the
moratorium that was in place and finally
will you commit today to release all
records fully unredacted by the end of
this week so congress and the american
people can know the truth about nih's
role and the origins of cover 19
so again senator i really pains me to
have to
just point out to the american public
how absolutely incorrect you are what
came out last night
on project veritas
was a grant that was submitted to darpa
then it distorted and said
we funded the grant we have never seen
that grant
and we have never funded that grand so
once again
you are completely and unequivocally
incorrect
when you join the darpa proposal
was a grant that we never saw and we did
not fund so you are incorrect our social
media will have all the supporting
documents and we'll be supporting the
senate record as well you are
you're backing down on this why don't we
go and look at
the veritas statement they were talking
about a grant
that was submitted to darpa are you
saying this was not are you saying that
this was viral gain of function research
i'm telling you that you're saying are
you saying that this was not viral gain
of function research by the definition
that you were very well aware
what your p3co definition is just a
legal ease to get away they'll allow you
to do this what i'm talking about
senator senator marshall if you please
allow the witness to respond
senator
we know and the misinformation
that the guide rails for what can be
done or not were not established by me
they were established by a three-year
process led by the office of science and
technology policy of the white house and
decided by you in a secret meeting at
the white house in december of 2019. uh
senator that is incorrect and this
refers exactly to what i was talking
about in response to senator rand paul
you are incorrect
completely and every time i try to
explain you're incorrect but the facts
are on my side so why would you not
commit to sharing everything
open under adapted with this congress so
so here's an example dr fauci uh this
hearing is critically important to the
american people
there are millions of people infected
with the cove environment it is
impacting every part of our economy
every family is asking for answers to
critical questions
both sides of the aisle have asked tough
questions but we are not going to allow
this committee hearing to be another
personal attack that undermines our
ability to deal with this
terrible virus that is impacting so many
people i will then turn to senator smith
thank you thank you senator
thank you thank you chair murray and
[Music]
i'll just let that go
so as we move into the third year of the
covet 19 response it seems to me that
our strategy is shifting we are shifting
from a goal of trying to get to zero
coveted cases to eradicating the virus
and our goal is really much more about
minimizing the damage of this pandemic
you and i have talked about this dr
faucia as well as with dr wolinski so we
need of course to minimize
hospitalizations and deaths caused by
covid we do that through vaccines and
through therapies
and we also need to minimize the covet
damage by understanding how to keep kids
in school
how to keep businesses open and
how to protect against
the damage that is caused by social
social isolation and burnout and other
stresses that injures our mental health
um it seems to me that while cove this
is happening well kova continues to
seriously stress our health care system
and while we still have people in this
country including sadly some members of
congress who continue to spread
misinformation and lies about the
pandemic
so it seems like we have to be realistic
that these cycles of the pandemic
until it becomes endemic are going to
continue we're going to probably
continue to see some unpredictable
variants arise
madam chair i just want to say that i i
hope that this committee can find some
time to discuss these issues as they
relate to
global vaccine strategy because
this is going to be crucial to our work
to protect americans health as we go
forward since we are not an island
but let me ask um
i'm very interested in how we think
about
like the data that is important for
americans to keep in their minds as
they're trying to measure relative risk
um last week public health experts
published some interesting articles that
suggested that we should maybe think
about incorporating
covid19 data into aggregate risk for all
respiratory viruses that are circulating
including the flu and rsv and you know
that maybe this data if we could look at
it in real time from medical facilities
and ers and so forth testing facilities
and private homes even would give us a
better picture of what's happening
so let me ask uh dr wolenski and dr
fauci if you could talk a little bit i
want to understand about this i want to
understand how you think about this
question of relative risk how we should
be transitioning and what we consider
from daily case counts for example to
looking at other data and particularly
how you
evaluate this idea of looking at
all respiratory illnesses in one basket
yeah senator smith this is such a
critically important question thank you
for raising this so um we have to do two
things simultaneously right now we're
dealing with an omicron surge where we
have the most number of cases we've ever
had in a day in this country and so we
have to get out of this omicron surge
but in the meantime we have to look down
the field and we have to understand what
is this going to look like when we're
not in a surge how do we deal with
endemic disease and what do we start
looking at with regard to endemic
disease and you're absolutely right we
need to think about the severity of that
disease because now what 62 percent of
americans vaccinated some of that
disease is not as severe as it was
that's a success of our vaccines we have
to look critically at hospital capacity
what can our hospitals handle um because
if people are coming in with covid or if
hospitals staff are out with covid
that's a really important measure that
we're going to look at and one of the
things we probably still are going to
examine although perhaps with less
import is the actual number of the cases
and why that's important um in general
is because it generally foreshadows
what's coming into the hospital so
knowing that and understanding what that
might mean for the future of
hospitalizations future severity future
capacity and all of those are things
that we're looking at right now but one
of the things that you critically
mentioned was our efforts in data
monetization how do we take the efforts
that we've had so far with kovid and
increase them continue to keep the pedal
to the metal as it were when we started
here we were not um collecting racial
and ethnicity data we didn't have a way
to
link in in a personal um
with personal identifiers removed
electronic health records with our
testing records we had 187 hospital
systems who could do that now we have 10
000 so what we really need to do is
scale up our data monetization efforts
and do it as you say not just for covid
but and not just for other respiratory
diseases like flu rsv um as you note but
for all diseases so um we're looking at
doing this for maternal mortality for
sickle cell disease for opioid um injury
for for many many diseases and this is
going to be the power of our data
modernization efforts and i'm really
grateful for resources from congress to
be able to leverage those thank you
thank you man i'm sure i believe i'm out
of time but i'll i've other questions if
we have a second round we will have a
second round senator smith tuberville
thank you madam chair thank you for
being here today
you know this administration has been in
charge of the
federal covert response for a year
i have to say i don't think it's been a
job well done our federal government not
only sets the tone
and the guidance for how millions of
americans should be handling covid
we set the standard for the world
our information has to be correct i
continue to hear that we need to follow
the science and i agree
but we have to
yet
hear
the clarity
from this administration
we hear conflicting guidance across the
board
in order to be effective guidance has to
be understood and implemented
by the average american
but most americans can't make heads or
tails of anything coming out of this
administration
so we are all
all of us are failing this test one
thing i do know is that when we finally
toward the end of this thing
congress is going to have an
investigation
we all know that
we've heard that the fda and president
biden say 55 years will be needed
to share data related to a lot of those
decisions
but we will have to investigate this
group will have to investigate and have
the information before 2076. heck most
of us won't be here in 2076.
this investigation will look into who
had authority to make decisions
i know there are more people making a
decision behind the scenes
so what i'd like to know is
i'm just concerned
how badly the response has been it's
handled you know president biden has
handled this in his first year we've
heard all the pluses and minuses this
administration
took office with three successful
vaccines and numerous effective
therapeutics and basically drove the
response into a ditch
at times it doesn't seem like anyone's
in charge
you started the year by dismantling
operation warp speed canceling contracts
monoclonal antibodies under investing
and testing and we've spent billions in
that first with delta now on omicron
people can't find a test i'm getting
text as we speak setting here where did
i get a test
we spent billions on this you know if we
can't find a test and test that and test
positive they can't get treatment uh
monoclonal antibodies are rationed
antiviral pills are months away so i
just got a simple question uh of all of
you up there and whoever wants to answer
this
if you have a problem and your
coordinates who do you go to who is the
head coach
of this virus that you have to go to
whether it's in the administration
whether it's one of you
dr fauci who do we go to
the person who's in charge of that is is
jeff science
who is in the white house at the white
house and we meet
very very regularly the entire medical
team as well as others
going over all of the data going over
what the strategies are going over what
the issues are what the problems are
what we've done right what we've done
wrong we examined it
literally continually sir has he done a
good job
you know i think given the circumstances
that we're in right now i believe he's
done a very good job
i really do this this is an
extraordinary virus
the likes of which we have not seen even
close to in well over 100 years
it is a very wily virus it has fooled
everybody all the time from the time it
first came in to delta to now omicron
very unpredictable and we're doing the
best we possibly can yeah
dr wolinski it's been reported by some
virologists and scientists that this
year around 170 people have died from
taking the regular flu vaccine
the vaccine advisory
adverse reporting system reported that
the number of people dying after or
following the covet vaccine is actually
in the thousands
now this is what i'm hearing
i'll give you a chance to refute that or
confirm it here you know is this true
are we having that many people die after
taking
one of these vaccines senator tuberville
thank you for that question the vaccine
adverse event reporting system is a
mandatory system of any adverse event
that happens after being vaccinated so
if you get hit by a car tragically after
getting vaccinated that gets reported in
the vaccine adverse avoiding system the
their system so the vaccines are
incredibly safe they protect us against
omicron they protect us against uh delta
they protect us against kovid they don't
protect us against every other form of
mortality out there do we keep numbers
of people that died following taking a
covet test from taking this vaccine do
we have any idea i'm just asking i'm
sorry those who have died after taking
following taking the vaccine is there
any number count do we keep records on
that that died of just uh from
absolutely yes i i couldn't give you
then the absolute number off the top of
my head but our staff could absolutely
get back in touch with you we collect
those data you know dr fauci
you have any clue on that about how many
died
100
i don't know the number but i think it's
really important for people michael
i'm sorry
i don't have a number but i think part
of the confusion is that when you do a
reporting
if you get vaccinated and you walk out
and get hit by a car
that is considered a debt i mean
that's the thing that gets confusing
that everything that happens after the
vaccination even if you die of something
completely obviously unrelated it's
considered a death so if i had
metastatic cancer got vaccinated and
died two weeks later that's a death that
gets i understand that and every one of
those is adjudicated
yeah one and one quick question before
we get through here i'm in rural alabama
but i get one of these home tests and i
test positive i have
asymptomatic
what do i do
people call what do i do i don't have a
doctor around what do i do thank you so
you're asymptomatic
you're asymptomatic no symptoms feel
well
yeah you stay home for five days and the
next five days if you continue to be
asymptomatic you can go out wear a mask
don't go traveling don't go to gyms
don't get real sick then what do i do
then well first you go and call your
physician and in fact i'd say you call
your physician regardless but call your
physician call your provider um if
you're continuing to have symptoms then
you stay home until your symptoms
resolve no therapeutics yeah
well that's where i would say call your
physician and see if you're eligible for
therapeutics a lot of these people don't
have physicians they've got a drug
senator we do need to move on thank you
senator rosen
thank you madam chair uh thank you
ranking member burr
this hearing is so very important i
really want to thank all of the
witnesses here for testifying today
your continued work thank you so much as
we
combat this pandemic in real time in
real time
and so first i just do want to echo the
concerns my colleagues have raised about
access to testing both in-person pcr
tests and the at home rapid tests we do
know that home test kits are scarce
americans are standing in extremely long
lines to get a cova test and hospital
emergency departments in my home state
of nevada have seen a significant
increase in people coming solely for
tests because there just aren't enough
alternatives and so this is just really
only adding to the stress as again i can
say speak to nevada on our health
systems nevada has been expanding our
testing options but increased federal
support on the ground in addition to
home testing
we feel is absolutely critical and in
the future the federal response must be
more proactive in this space
and so i'm a little bit concerned that
about the testing keeping up with the
variance because we are ha this is all
happening in real time covet is evolving
you don't know which strain may become
the dominant strain and so we want to
ensure just in addition to the
effectiveness of the vaccines and
therapeutics that the testing
um
accuracy must also keep up so dr fauci
with some recent reports about the
current variant settling more in the
throat than in the nose for some
patients
what are we doing with the
development and deployment of rapid at
home tests based on saliva versus a
nasal swab and then dr woodcock how
rapidly do you think
the over-the-counter testing can be
delivered approved you know looked at
approved delivered to the american
public to make sure that they're uh less
anxious
thank you for that uh question senator
yes there have been recent reports
uh that in fact the
um
sensitivity and the ability to detect
in a swab of the throat versus the
nasopharynx at least with omicron that's
a preliminary report i think it needs to
be validated and verified if the data
are strong enough
then we the company whatever who makes
that will likely go to the fda
to ask to change the indication for
because the emergency use authorization
is for a nasal swab if the data the
scientific data indicate that it's
better to get an oral or other swab they
would present that to the fda so i would
leave that to dr woodcock to answer the
rest of that question thank you
certainly well we can act very rapidly
but first i would like to say people
should not use swabs that are designed
as nasal swabs and try to swab their
throat they may stab themselves okay
that would not be good okay
what we need to do is have tests that
you know see whether the um
the
throat swab as dr fauci said could
provide more sensitivity we do know the
tests are picking up omicron but right
now with less sensitivity than they did
some of the other variants
as far as time as i said
after
the itap program does the testing at nih
fda has been able to
approve authorize within a day or two of
getting those data
however
the companies would have to change the
test configuration to accommodate the
swab the larger swab that you'd use in
the throat that's probably what would
take the most time as well seeing
whether that was better and and to
continue with that point as we've
seen with some of the testing uh the
reagents or the the materials that it
really takes to use the test is there
the ability for people to return a test
that might no longer work can those
agents any of that be recycled or
upcycled if they're returned to the
company uh on on open like how can i
how do we not dispose them and not get
some recyclability out of that is that
possible in some way we can get back to
you on those parameters be happy to do
that
thank you i appreciate that um
i'd like to talk a little bit again
people are talking about the public
health data um
you know we're noting about all the
daily statistics
noting about some of the statistics
about
possibly death and so positive or
negative uh critical um that this data
is critical even for us to make our
decisions as far as what we fund and
sometimes there's notes to say that we
shouldn't include home testing in the
daily statistics because they might not
be reliable so dr belinsky to build on
some of that testing and the statistics
that you need to do your job that all of
us need to do our job how's the cdc
working with the state local health our
hospitals to be sure that the voluntary
self-reporting guidance
it is going to be accurate and give us
the kind of statistics we need going
forward yeah thank you for that question
senator so um we are routinely reporting
pcr tests that is what is routinely
reported from the state and that is what
our updated statistics are there are um
there's passive reporting that occurs
with rapid tests but i also want to in
uh understand the importance of rapid
tests at home tests for people to be
empowered to use these rapid tests to do
the right thing so regardless of whether
we can count them generally they tend to
be people who have milder symptoms they
might have been vaccinated have a runny
nose and they decide to go and get a
rapid test and do the test at home
less important is counting that case
than it is that that person stay home
isolate do the right thing and not
before transmitting so i think that many
of these tests have different purposes
but one of the really important purposes
of these rapid tests even if we don't
count them is to empower the public to
do the right thing through this pandemic
thank you thank you very much senator
romney
thank you
thank you madam chairman um
uh
just a couple of thoughts one it's uh
it's been two hours since we've been
here it's one of the people the low
level here out of the
out on the the hinterlands just just a
couple of thoughts one i think it would
be helpful if the
and
please excuse me for this comment if the
chair and ranking member limited their
opening comments to the five minutes
just like you expect those folks to
limit their comments to five minutes we
didn't get started until 25 minutes
after asking these folks their questions
um i i do want to note uh
also that that in this process as i'm
sure you who are testifying here today
recognize that some of what we do is
performing
and some of what we do is to become
informed
and uh i do both uh from time to time so
i'm not uh
just in one camp or the other in that
regard but i do want to point out
how much
i personally and i believe the great
majority of the people in our country
respect you individually and
professionally for the work that you do
you are scientists not politicians
uh nevertheless you are being made
subject to the
uh the political whims uh of of various
political individuals and and that comes
at a high cost which unfortunately i i
fear will lead some to not want to
participate
in in helping our government
make scientific choices
but i'd very deeply appreciate your your
commitment to the american people and
your desire to do things as well as we
possibly know how to do
that doesn't mean they'll be done
perfectly
that doesn't mean you won't make
mistakes doesn't mean there won't be
changes from time to time sometimes as
data comes in that's different than what
you had anticipated
and sometimes just because you were
wrong i mean it's the nature of being a
human being that's where where we are i
think unfortunately the administration
was wrong
in not uh
building testing capacity at a time when
uh when we all thought covert was kind
of going away i remember the summer and
the and the fall going into a grocery
structure being to a drug store and
seeing two rapid tests on the shelf
and those things stayed there for days
no one was interested in buying a rapid
test
and apparently the administration didn't
think that it should be aggressively
building rapid tests but omicron came
along cut people by surprise and we were
we were obviously
badly mistaken
the administration was and and were
suffering in part because of that
let me ask with regards to pax lovin uh
miss o'connell um
is that being subject to warp speed my
understanding is that that paxlovit is
far superior
uh to other oral uh antivirals should we
not be much more aggressively producing
that and getting that out such that it
can be prescribed
thank you senator romney we're in active
conversations with pfizer about how to
increase
uh their their time limits my
understanding and you know the
scientists on the panel can
feel free to jump in is that the process
required in order to generate this
particular antiviral is months long it's
a chemical process it's one that's very
very hard to accelerate what we have
been able to do is to find additional
doses to work with pfizer to try to
unlock additional capacity where they
can find it
and we're continuing to do that actively
thank you
dr wolinski good to see you again and
appreciate the chance we had to speak
earlier this week or last week rather
as i've looked on the cdc's covid
tracker report i note the data goes
through november 20th
and i remember my days in business if we
if we didn't have daily information we
couldn't make good decisions and and i
wonder
do we need to invest in either
developing a new uh sub-agency or a task
force to get
basically on you know
immediate data daily data so we know
what's going on and that's not just for
the public that's for for those of you
who are making those decisions do we
need to do a much better job moving
faster getting data um senator first of
all let me thank you for your earlier
comments but also to comment on our
cover data tracker i think you're
speaking to the seven
i'm sorry the 27 jurisdictions that we
now compile data that allows those
jurisdictions to comply to
report together their testing data their
cases data their immunizations data
their age data as well as their death
data it's over two-thirds of the country
that we do and we update that about once
a month and it's about three or four
weeks in a rear so
mid-january we will be having data
through the end of december and it
simply does take that long for our
jurisdictions to compile those data and
of course our death data are generally
lagging it takes a while for those to
get reported and adjudicated so um we're
now updating those are about of six
weeks in a year and that's and we're
working hard to to keep those in in real
time yeah i i note retailers like uh uh
like zara for instance they unders
apparently get data and correlate it uh
daily uh so i'd hope we could we could
find a way to increase the speed with
which we get that data i know my my time
is up i'm just going to make a comment
and that is that uh
i think it'd be helpful if people knew
when they should get tested
when it's called for because i think a
lot of individuals myself included get
tested when there's no indication that i
need to get tested other than just want
to make sure i'm not sick
and and there's huge demand for tests
which are in short supply in part
because of that and number two when you
say when people have been exposed
please let us know what it means to be
exposed we're in a room right now i sure
i'm sure someone here has omicron are we
all exposed
and therefore need to get tested
what does it mean to be exposed and when
do we need to get tested though
i know that i wanted to ask that of dr
fauci i can't do that given my time
those are topics i'd love to have
senator romney
i think that is a question we all want
answered and i i will i will give uh dr
fatchy the opportunity to respond to
that dr fauci
well
the cdc guidelines make that very clear
and it is if you are exposed to an
individual with known if you are in a
period of 15 minutes at a time or a
total of 15 minutes over a 24-hour
period in a situation where you come
into close contact uh perhaps dr
valencia could expand on that but that's
the fundamental core of the cdc
guidelines that's exactly right in terms
of the definition of exposure in terms
of who should get tested you should get
tested if you have symptoms of covet 19.
if you do a rapid at home test and you
continue to have symptoms and that test
is negative you should do another test
or get a pcr
you should get it tested within five
days of your exposure or after five days
of your exposure with the definition
that dr fauci
mentioned and
you know we're testing through tests to
stay and other mechanisms as well so
many reasons to test
but really most importantly if you are
exposed if you have symptoms and also if
you're going into a setting where you
might be seeing an immunocompromised
person somebody who's vulnerable not
able to be um to take a vaccine okay
thank you very much
uh senator casey
murray thank you very much
for this hearing and i want to start by
commending the public service of
all the members of the panel
dr wolinski dr fauci dr woodcock and
assistant secretary o'connell this is
difficult work
and we appreciate your public service in
particular i want to
reiterate um statements i think i've
made had to make before
in light of dr fauci's
commendable public service not just in
the middle of this pandemic throughout
the pandemic but also
for decades i think i speak for a lot of
people back home and across the country
that
not only have confidence in your uh
integrity
but also your pro your uh
your work in uh in public health
and so we're grateful for that
let me start with a question for dr
wolinski
dr i'm quoting from a statement you made
on friday on television
in the context of a question about
covet 19 death and i'll quote
two sentences one is
quote the overwhelming number of deaths
over 75 percent
occurred in people who had at least
four
comorbidities
so really these are people who were
unwell to begin with and yes
really encouraging the news and the
context of omicron unquote
now this statement
and i know it was part of a broader
interview
caused great concern i know from my work
um as a senator
uh for years
that
uh you and your team at cdc whether it's
your the policy or the work that you do
that policy and that work are both
focused on
ensuring that all americans receive
the best possible treatment
and protection this is especially
important for
for older adults and people with
disabilities who may need
additional supports and protections
so context is important in the in in an
interview like this
so please explain what point you were
making that's number one the point
you're making and secondly
outline cdc's commitment to protecting
older adults and people with
disabilities as we continue to address
the pandemic
senator casey i'm really grateful for
the opportunity to
explain this and
you know to step back that interview on
friday i recently spoke to a study on
the high level of protection against
vaccines it was a pre-taped interview
and much of it was cut and that phrase
was taken out of context as you note
the study was a cohort of 1.2 million
people who were vaccinated and 36 people
passed
demonstrating the remarkable
effectiveness of our vaccines but no
less tragic is the 36 people who passed
because of coven 19 and that many of
them had co-morbidities comorbidities
that i've spent my career taking care of
some comorbidities that just prior to
coming to the cdc we saw time and time
again disproportionately impacting
people with covet 19 and the hospitals
that i cared for patients so what are we
doing at cdc given the critical
importance will we have toolkits for
covet 19 for patients with disabilities
we have accessible materials that are
available in braille in american sign
language so that people with
disabilities in easier to read and
understand language so that people with
disabilities can access our materials we
have improved data collection systems on
our cova data tracker you can track
vaccination status by disability and
we've worked with states to make sure
that those are reporting and then we're
funding partners in our public health
partners to do more for patients with
disability and if anything this issue on
friday has redoubled our commitment to
continuing to make sure that we have
access for people with disabilities
thank you for allowing me to clarify
well i appreciate that and i
appreciate the time you took to respond
it i would also suggest and
maybe even ask you to to spend some time
meeting with
leaders from both the disability and
aging communities to walk through what
you just walked through and even expand
beyond that we're already planning thank
you thanks very much
i want to turn now to vaccine
development for for children
the recent setbacks in vaccine trials
for children under five is of great
concern so many parents
are exhausted from this pandemic
so i know we can't change the outcome of
the trials but we can't take steps to
reassure parents that the young children
will still get vaccinated as soon as
possible
dr fauci dr woodcock if you could
briefly talk about
these trials and
any
anything you can tell us about
speeding up the development of safe and
effective vaccines for children under
five
thank you for that question senator i'll
take a quick shot at it and then pass it
over to dr woodcock
the situation that i believe the public
needs to understand is that the trials
from children from six months to four
years was broken up into two groups
it was six months to 24 months 24 months
to four years
and in the dosage that was used
the individual the children the younger
group
the trial met the end point of
non-inferiority comparing it to what
would be the standard of what would be
success
however for the middle group the 24
months to four year group they did not
meet that standard of non-inferiority
so because of that it was felt that this
likely will be a three dose
vaccination for children in that group
so the trials are being done now as
quickly as possible to see if they can
get that data to have a uniform dose and
a uniform regimen but i'll pass it over
to dr woodcock
yeah well of course i can't say a lot
but we are working very closely with the
manufacturers the vaccines
on
accelerating and making sure that
vaccines are available for the youngest
children
thank you very much
thank you senator murkowski
thank you mr chairman madam chairman
it uh it says a lot about 2021 when the
uh
most appreciated gift under the
christmas tree in our family was coveted
kits for everybody
um i'm still getting thank yous for
those
dr wolinski there has been a lot of
discussion here today about the uh some
of the confusion with guidance and um
just some very clear asks
to tell us
what that is so
a question that i'm going to forward to
you from a teacher
is if
if the teacher is fully vaccinated
boosted
test positive for covid
but after they test positive they feel
pretty fine there's no fever there's no
nothing after five days can that teacher
return to school
without
testing negative
just so long as that individual wears a
mask yes thank you
that's exactly what i needed to know i'm
going to be having a meeting
zoom meeting later this afternoon with
several different
alaska-based companies that have more
than 100 employees
they're quite concerned about
the the mandate that requires testing of
unvaccinated
employees we all know that this is this
is under litigation now and
um things may change on that but right
now their real concern is if this goes
into place and we are required to
ensure that these unvaccinated
individuals receive testing
right now testing all around the state
is is in limited supply the front page
of the anchorage daily news shows the
line of cars that are waiting to to get
their their pcr test
you can't find the at-home tests
available in the stores now
it is
it is becoming harder and harder
and then again if you really do have a
mandate in place it's going to require
this so i know that the question has
been asked about what more is is being
done i know we've heard
the extraordinary uh federal resources
that have gone that way
but the facts on the ground remain
that we are in an extraordinarily short
supply of testing whether it's the
at-home kits or whether it's the ability
to to get the testing that you need
it's cold back home right now and my
hearts go out to those workers who are
working in the outdoor
um drive-in
where they have to go out when it's when
it's
20 below as it is in fairbanks um
that's more of a of a statement rather
than a question there but i think it is
important for folks to realize that we
are we're still in a very difficult
place when it comes to accessibility dr
wilinski this is a question for you and
you and i have had many conversations
last year about the specific impact of
conditional sale orders as it relates to
the cruise industry
that industry was effectively shut down
for all of of 2020 and we were able to
salvage a bit of it as things relaxed
last year
but in fairness the industry itself has
undertaken extraordinary precautions as
one industry
to make sure that people are protected
from from this virus so the question to
me to you
is i want to make sure that alaskan
communities and businesses can
can have a season this coming year and
right now people are making their
decisions as to whether or not to book a
trip to alaska for the summer or not
i understand the conditional sale order
is is set to expire in a few days in
recognition
that the companies have practices that
adhere to or even exceed the guidance in
the order so
i i guess i'd like some assurance from
you that that they can count on that
that that
this is clear guidance and messaging to
uh to those within the industries and
and to those who are counting on being
able to to have a season this coming
summer
yeah thank you senator and i think the
conditional sales order and the fact
that the industry has stepped up and is
now interested in doing and exceeding as
you know the the compliance with the
sale order without the order even
necessarily needing to be in place is a
is a real testimony to how well that has
worked and how we work collaboratively
with the industry
um what i can say is that you know just
over the last two weeks with omicron
we've seen a 30-fold increase in cases
on ships um
during this season because of omicron so
well i
anticipate that with ships following
conditional sail order we still will
continue to follow do the oversight and
watch and do all the technical
assistance and support in every single
way we anticipate that this order will
not be renewed and that the cruise ship
industries will continue to understand
that this is a really safe practice for
those industries what i can't predict is
what the summer will bring
understand that but for right now you
expect this guidance to stay in place
that's my anticipation thank you thank
you madam chairman thank you senator
hickenlooper
now tom
thank you madam chair
ranking member chair
all right uh
first i want to reiterate a little bit
of what about what senator romney said
um
you know i
was the odd one out i was uh worked as a
scientist for a number of years and i
was
a mayor of a big city and was pretty
much the only scientist among all the
bears
and i was a governor and pretty much the
only scientists around
governors
and now i'm the only scientist among
centers
and
i recognize from that long list of
experience the frustration that
you must feel
having to put up with the attacks and
assaults
when you're out there trying to do your
job and something that each of you have
committed to is it the service of
society
anyway i just want you to know that i
appreciate
how difficult science is it's not
perfect and when you combine that with
the complexity of dealing with any large
bureaucracy
i'm not making apologies these are just
like
you know just like any
well we're having a war against this
virus and just like in any
wartime situation mistakes have have
serious consequences but i appreciate
more than i can say how much work
you all have done and and
i don't think anyone here
thinks you're not trying your very best
all the time i really appreciate that uh
dr fauci
uh i think one of the problems
we haven't gotten far enough on is
innovation and how do we
stimulate innovation to go faster and
better how do we increase the
not just the breadth of our vaccines but
the durability so that as we get the
next wave i'm i'm not sure how many
letters there are in the greek greek
alphabet but i know there's going to be
another one
and
in that process
because i think we are this country is
known for innovation it is the one of
the
tools that we have that we know work i'm
hoping that will you can take the
opportunity to be a little bit
optimistic
and feel that you're not going to be
judged and held accountable because i
think people want to hear that we are
going to come through and begin to look
at some of these things successfully
well well thank you very much senator
for your original kind comments and i'll
answer your question
now as you know as a scientist that
there are fundamental basic issues that
are discovery that once you get the
discovery then you could do the
implementation of that discovery we were
very fortunate
in that the basic research and clinical
research investments that had been made
literally for decades
prior to the
new
revelation that we had a very
threatening virus among us was the
reason why
we were able to use new platform
technologies as well as image and design
to get highly
successful and safe vaccines
that same thing is going on right now
it isn't well known because it isn't
front page yet and you know as a
scientist when you're doing your basic
research it's only until you get the
result that people really understand
what you've been doing there's a lot of
investment
not only in improving
the vaccines that we have
for covid for saurus kovi ii but a lot
of work as i mentioned in my opening
statement
about looking at using the tools of
fundamental basic and applied science to
develop next generation of vaccines
particularly
universal coronavirus vaccines or at
least universal sauce called v2 vaccines
so we won't be chasing after the next
variant that we'll be able to have a
vaccine that has the capability of
responding to every iteration of a
variant and there's a lot of work going
on with that right now but again when
you're doing basic research as you can
appreciate as well more than anyone that
usually isn't very well recognized by
the public
point made
um in terms of testing and a parallel
thought dr woodcock maybe you can
address this the the testing now is by
the time it gets the retail somewhere in
the 15 to 20 dollar range uh maybe as
high as 22 or 23 dollars in some places
uh
is there the prospect of there because i
keep reading about different approaches
to testing that we might
find a way to do reduce the cost of
testing down to said instead of 15 could
be 15 cents or at least for the chemical
side of it i realize then you've got to
manufacture it and put it in cases and
you know packaging
maybe you can provide a little optimism
on that
sure well i believe the red program
which congress provided funding for
quite some time ago
is really
cutting edge and they have a sort of a
shark tank approach they're really
looking for innovation they are they
provide assistance to developers and i
really believe that's promising that we
will come up with uh additional
technologies easier to manufacture and
actually easier for people to use and
cheaper
great thank you and i i have obviously
more questions but i'll i'll yield the
floor back
thank you for now
senator braun
thank you madam chair
reading the paper last night
lead editorial
in the washington post and
i about dropped it when i read the first
paragraph
it's taught in the title of the
editorial is living with covid
quite understandably the coronavirus
pandemic at first
was a dire emergency
but it can't be won
forever
the crisis will have to shift
to a manageable
health threat without massive disruption
and overwhelming anxiety
president biden has been fighting the
virus as an emergency
in his first year but a shift
must come before too long
never thought i'd read anything like
that
in a place like washington post but i
think
it reflects
where we're at in the journey and
generally when you wrestle with
something of this magnitude
where it's dominated the conversation
for now two years
and you're still seeing results
similar to
if not worse
from when we started
it would beg the question
do we need to take a different approach
it's been very top-down
been put in place
i think
understandably by the agencies that
would be most pertinent
but when you look at the results
you look at the fact that
a third of the country for whatever
reason
is not going to get
vaccinated you got a mandate
that now
is going to force the hand
and when you get someplace like the
washington post
saying that we got to take a different
approach
i'm wondering do we have it within our
constitution here
when we've been bought in
for so long
that this is the way it's got to be
listened to senator casey
earlier made a very good point
everybody talks about data
paying attention to the data
and when this is so ravaged
uh such a small percentage
so significantly of a population
with comorbidities
that are elderly
it just keeps saying why don't we change
the approach
you don't want to have the legacy
of being
a country in disruption
and full
of anxiety
and kind of what i'm hearing here today
i'm not sensing
that
we're going to see a real change in
approach
and even more so
doubling down
on what now for two years
has arguably
not gotten us in a place
where we feel better about it where
we're not
drowning in anxiety
and
i'm going to pose the question to dr
woodcock you've been
involved in federal health care in one
way or another
for a long time acting commissioner at
the fda
normally
a board of directors
a ceo
would be fired as a ceo number one
a board of directors would be questioned
in terms of how good they are meaning
maybe us here in the senate
to where
you're not directing for something other
than what we've had which in my opinion
would be decentralizing it providing the
information to the american public
to make
their own best decisions
dr woodcock do you think that
is
sensible
do you think the washington post makes
sense
and are you willing to change up there
on this panel to reflect accordingly
well i think that we're talking about a
natural disaster and you can
fire your board of directors uh because
your factory was devastated by a
hurricane a tornado or a wildfire but i
don't know whether that would improve
the situation i think right now we need
to focus on continuity of operations for
hospitals
and
other essential services as
this variant sweeps through the
population
i don't think that will last a really
long time
but that's what i where i think we are
right now so i don't think prior
um
[Music]
you know approaches reflect what's going
on right now i think it's hard to
process
what's actually happening right now
which is
most people are going to get covered
all right and what we need to do is make
sure the hospitals can still function
transportation
you know other essential services are
not disrupted while this happens i think
after that will be a good time to
reassess
uh how we're approaching
this uh pandemic i'm out of time but i
think if you want to regain the trust of
the american public
you probably need to look at a total
revamp
on what we do in terms of how we contend
with it
over the next year or so or i think
you're going to get more forceful
editorials from places that you would
never imagine if you keep doing the same
thing generating the same results
that isn't the formula for success in
any endeavor
thank you senator baldwin
thank you
madam chair and i want to
thank all of our witnesses today and i
also want to just
underscore
the preface that uh our colleague
senator romney gave to his um
his questioning um
i i like the way he described it
sometimes we come to perform sometimes
we come to be informed
and um i i guess i would just uh
speculate a little bit beyond that if
there were to be a true tit for tat on
the performance angle
um
there's any number of
areas we could go i reflect on
proposals for ultraviolet light and
drinking bleach and drinking uh hydro
hydroxychloroquine
we could go there but it's not
constructive
and so i'm going to be constructive in
my questions and i just urge my
colleagues to do that we're all in this
together
and we have a duty
uh
to act responsibly in that fashion and
again thank you to our uh our
witnesses
um dr wellinsky i'm going to start with
you on a topic that i bring up
frequently when you're in our presence
and that is
the tools we have now to sequence do
genomic sequences
to better understand variants to better
track variants
i know that there's been much investment
in that
i'd like to hear
what tools that we have in place now
that we didn't before and what you see
the future of
this genomic sequencing is especially as
this committee looks at
pandemic preparation for future
potential pandemics
thank you senator baldwin and for your
championing our ability to
to ramp up our genomic sequencing
efforts and the resources from the
american rescue plan once at 0.7 billion
dollars really did allow us to detect
omicron swiftly so maybe i'll just give
tell you the story of what happened with
omicron and that is we heard about this
variant that was coming from south
africa and we didn't know if it was here
yet but we did know it had this unique
footprint of the s gene target failure
on pcr so what we did immediately after
hearing about this is to enhance
surveillance for this footprint
and to enhance sequencing so that any uh
sequence that had this footprint i
shouldn't say any many sequences that
have this footprint we were specifically
looking for um for this omicron variant
within days we found it um so within
three days i think that we started doing
this enhanced surveillance and then
within days we had you know tens 40s um
by about four days later by december 5th
is when we started detecting it in our
background genomic sequencing so that
background genomic sequencing now does
tens of thousands of sequences a week
it's a collaboration with academic
partners industry commercial labs cdc
labs public health partners to do tens
of thousands of sequences a week and
what we do is we look at the number
of cases that are out there and our goal
is to detect a variant that is present
at
0.1 percent
with 99 confidence so that we see the
menu of the variants that are out there
we
are enthusiastic about this program we
are intending to ramp up this program
for potentially other viruses but the
potential to do so there for other um
foodborne outbreaks as well as for um
wastewater
investigation we have the capacity to do
that there as well so again thank you
for championing this effort which truly
did allow us to detect omicron in in
real record speed thank you
thank you
um
next um assistant secretary o'connell uh
when we last met uh uh at this committee
um i asked you for a commitment that a
significant portion of the 10 billion
dollars for the defense production act
funding that i help secure as part of
the american rescue plan be invested in
the raw materials needed to make n95
masks here in america
the alarming spread of omicron has made
the need for n95s
even more clear
and yet
asper has not spent any of this american
rescue plan funding on the raw material
needed to make n95
in n95s in america well it has invested
3.1 billion on other priorities
primarily using prior supplemental
funding
the fda reports now that 60
of the kn 95 masks that are being
imported from china are fake
and americans still can't go to a local
pharmacy and purchase an american-made
n95 so president biden has now
personally urged americans to upgrade
the quality of the masks they wear i
want to know when the american people
will be able to buy an american-made and
95 mask that they know will protect them
and when we can expect asper to
invest the american rescue plan funding
into the raw materials necessary
senator baldwin thank you for that
question you can buy an n95 mask
manufactured in america now we have 737
million of those in the strategic
national stockpile
we are also in the process uh this month
we hope to award or next month you know
as contracts go uh to award an agreement
for warm based manufacturing of n95
masks uh what we're asking
the vendors to return to us as part of
the proposal is their ability to
manufacture 141 million masks a month
at a surge capacity and to be able to
maintain that manufacturing at a 20 to
30 percent rate uh in times where demand
is not as high so we are very invested
in n95 masks being made available and
we'll continue to look and i appreciate
your support uh
in getting us the american rescue plan
dollars that we're currently
investing and we'll continue to look at
the right ways to invest that have
really appreciated the conversations you
and i have had around that
thank you very much
i appreciate the witnesses have been
here well over two and a half hours we
are going to have a second round of
questions um so i'm going to recess for
10 minutes
to allow a break for our witnesses we
will reconvene at 12 45.
um
recently
these strike teams provide medical
personnel and other supports that help
nursing homes get through the surges
like the one that
we're seeing right now on the 22nd of
december of last year
i along with three of my colleagues sent
a letter to secretary becerra asking
how health and human services
was protecting nursing home
residents and workers
in the current 19 surge including the
distribution of booster shots
what is hhs doing to ensure nursing
homes have the supports they need to
protect residents and workers
who care for those residents
senator casey thank you so much for your
question
we share your concern for
nursing home staff and long-term care
facility residents and have continued to
do all we can
to make sure they have access to boosts
we've worked with the pharmacies to
bring in
vaccination clinics bring those to the
long-term care facilities and skilled
nursing facilities
so the
vaccines are available on the ground and
the residents don't have to travel or
access the vaccines
on their own
in addition asper has been sending since
the beginning of the pandemic or since
the beginning that these tests were
available 2.8 million tests per week to
long-term care facilities across the
country we know how important it is
that
they're able to to surveil any disease
in their facilities and having access to
these tests is one of the ways they can
stay on top of where they are
so we share your concern and we'll look
forward to responding to your letter
thanks very much
senator
thank you madam chairman um
ms woodcock
i know you said a
while ago that you
you're
excited about what rad x accomplished
and i think we all are
um but fda issued revised guidance
stating that it would focus
its review efforts on at home test and
point of care covet test applications
from developers with the capacity to
manufacture more than 500 000 tests per
week within three months of being
authorized
why did the fda move the goal post at
this particular time
and suggest to
companies that can't ramp up to that
manufacturing that they're not going to
get an accelerated eua pathway
well because of what
some of the members have been discussing
over the last several hours that we have
an urgent need for high volume
home
based
test and we have a queue
we have done moved heaven and earth
to get
as many done as possible we've approved
over 400 different kinds of tasks or
test collection devices during this
pandemic
but as far as what the queue is a
priority we're prioritizing the highest
volume and just putting them to the
front uh so that we can get uh
home tests and kits into the hands of
contact i i get what you're doing my
question is this what does this say to
the innovative company that's out there
that doesn't have the manufacturing
capacity and and
without us marrying them to a large
manufacturing capacity
it's basically saying don't innovate
because you're not going to get
consideration under the eua if you don't
have a manufacturing capacity of 500 000
tests a week
it says these are prioritized it doesn't
say we won't get to the others
well get to the others i mean this is
there's all a sense of urgency here i
just think that
that might have
been thought of before we did this let
me go to you mr connell um
i'm i'm really challenged on this
procurement of 500 million tests as you
can tell and
one i i don't understand why there's not
been a release that came out of
asper
uh or barda uh publicly announcing
here's how many we've contracted that
i've got to find it somewhere in a dod
contract that a very limited amount of
people go to certainly not one that i
regularly looked at
but
based on one of your contracts we've got
13.6 million tests
costing 190 million dollars i think
that's from the vodka distributor
um
when i break that down that's about 14 a
test now cms just put out a new rule
that mandated
that insurers must cover
up to eight tests per person per week
per month
for a family of four that's 32 tests and
that they can reimburse at 12
now if i'm a manufacturer and i'm under
a 12 reimbursement
or i can go over here and i can sell
directly to the federal government and
get 14
i'm probably going to sell the federal
government and get 14
where where where am i wrong
thank you senator burr we continue to
work to access the tests that will be
distributed as part of the 500 million
and the tests that you're referring to
so first of all uh dod by tradition has
put out whenever we've done an assisted
acquisitions with them
they put out within the first 24 hours
of that contract going out an
announcement that the contract has gone
out so that's what you're seeing and
that's been uh do rigor it's been what
the way dod has approached us
through our entire relationship
we're continuing
why is why is aspernam putting out a
similar
uh public statement we'd be happy to and
thank you senator i'll go back and talk
to the communications team and see if
there's a companion
press release that makes sense for us to
put out
well i'm not sure you addressed my
concern which is it's more profitable to
settle the federal government than it is
put it on retail
based upon the reimbursements that this
administration has now required of
insurers i hope you'll think about that
uh this is alarming to me
and as we've all displayed there are no
tests out there
there are no tests on the shelves of
walgreens cvs that people can go in buy
and take home and
and do it so it makes even more
confusing cdc's
policy that if you want to take a test
go ahead and take it it's not required
but you can take it you can't get it
uh dr fauci just very quickly
uh south african data suggests that
omicron may have
an ability to build immunity to delta
delta does not have an immunity
to it does not build an immunity to
omicron um
have you got any comments on that
cypress uh
announced a delta crom
variant are you worried about that
and we've been about three weeks behind
israel throughout this whole
thing
and even though we've seen south african
data go up and go back down very quickly
israel epidemiologists just this week
said they expect that for the next two
weeks they will see a doubling of the
infections in israel meaning they're not
following the same timeline that we saw
in south africa how should we interpret
that for the u.s
okay thank you very much for those
questions senator with regard to the
cross protection i think it's too early
to tell because you're dealing with
multiple
population demography of people who've
been previously infected vaccinated or
what have you it seems pretty clear
that if you get infected with omicron
you're going to get good protection
against omicron but also good protection
against some of the other spillovers so
we really yet to have seen and i think
the basis of your question is a
reasonable one if we wind up getting
infected with omicron at a very very low
level of pathogenicity is that going to
be sort of almost like a live attenuated
vaccine i don't think we can say that
right now we really have to see how
things spread out when we see
how that
of affairs in the next variant so there
will be invariably another variant we're
going to have to take a look at whether
or not there's going to be any
protection there that's the first thing
with regard to the delta cron this new
variant right now even though it's got
you know a bunch of mutations that
people look at it is not something that
at least the who who's looked at this
carefully feels that that has to be
something that is of great concern but
we always
keep our eye on it to make sure so when
you say it's not of a great concern now
the one encouraging thing about it it's
that it's been around for a while it
isn't something that just propped up and
yet omicron completely outstripped it as
did delta so it doesn't look like it has
the capability of being transmissible
enough to be a problem nonetheless we
still keep an eye out on it with regard
to to israel i mean i'm not sure i'm
sorry i forgot your question about
israel could you repeat it and we are
way over time here they run about three
weeks in front of us yeah yet their
experience is not up and down
drastically like south africa data
begins to show they went up and now it
looks like over the next two week their
epidemiologists say it's going to double
and maybe double again
before they hope it comes down what
should we expect yeah i think it's
that's a great question senator but what
it really reflects is that when you have
an outbreak of a particular variant how
high it goes up when it peaks and comes
down is a reflection of what the status
is in your country because if you look
at what you saw
in south africa they were almost free of
delta when they got omicron so omicron
sort of had the unfettered capability of
going way up and way down when you talk
about what happened in israel that's a
different population it's a mostly
vaccinated population so they're likely
going to see breakthrough infections in
the united states we have such a large
country with such differences in
vaccinations versus infections etc that
we believe we will see it peak and we
will see it come down but it's very
difficult to predict whether it's going
to be a sharp decrease or whether it's
going to do this our own feeling and i
believe that dr wolinski feels the same
way as i do that it's going to vary
depending upon where in the country you
are how much infection you had
previously what at the level of
vaccination is so we may see a peak up
and down in some regions of the country
and a peak up and doing this in other
regions of the country thank you thank
you very much senator smith
thank you madam chair um
i'd like to ask a question of dr
wolinski if i could
i think we all know that americans need
better access to rapid testing and this
is a big deal for us in terms of trying
to figure out what are our health risks
how do we protect ourselves and how do
we also go about our lives and i think
that we are making headway here that we
have a long way to go um dr wolinski i'd
like you to talk about this issue of how
we should be or not collecting and
analyzing the data from rapid home tests
should we be incorporating this data
into um like should we try to capture
that data um is this important for local
communities as they're trying to make
decisions about masking and other
public health strategies that they want
to deploy should we be thinking of the
data from rapid tests as a tool for
individual risk assessment or as an
important tool for population level
understanding of what's happening how do
you see that yeah thank you so much
senator smith so we have been using the
pcr test not the rapid tests the lab
tests the molecular tests
um to really capture our case counseling
really get a good view of where we are
in terms of the epidemiology
anticipating what was going to be coming
into the hospitals but the south tests
are a really important valuable tool for
people to empower themselves their own
health to to not expose themselves to
other people to get some information
about their own health and so if an
individual were to test positive if
they're feeling unwell they should
certainly consult with a health care
provider consult with a pharmacist and
your health department
but if you're feeling well then use that
rapid test to say okay my test was
positive i need to stay home and isolate
protect myself from the community
protect myself or the community for me
and protect me
you know my loved ones so that they
don't get infected themselves and i
think that it's less about the absolute
case count of understanding whether you
have asymptomatic infection or a runny
nose and your rapid test is positive
then it is really about empowering you
to do the right thing and not be for
transmitting
and could you talk a little bit about
what other countries are doing are other
countries and trying to incorporate this
rapid testing data into their population
metrics um
how is that working in other places
around the world um some countries are
and some countries aren't um london and
uk have been doing more uh reporting of
rapid testing but they too are saying
that they're they're missing i think
somewhere around 40 percent i'd have to
confirm that number but they too um well
they capture more than than we have
tried to
they also agree that they're missing
some as well okay thank you very much um
madam sure i'm going to see back the
rest of my time i just want to
acknowledge something i think has been
going on here today that i think just
deserves being called out
you know
dr fauci has been the target of a
concerted and coordinated campaign
of disinformation and distortion and
personal attacks um and
then he's being blamed
for
all of this hatred and anger that has
been generated against him and i mean i
think we just need to be honest here
that um this is being done by some
members of the republican party that are
using it for fundraising
i'm not saying that that's happening by
members and this i'm just saying that
that's happening i was just pointed out
to me that somebody sent out um earlier
this you know in 2021 i found you for
prison email
so i just think it's important that we
i have to call this out
and
i think it's important that we
we see it and we we have to try to rise
above this kind of of of behavior
our committee here should be focusing on
these kinds of kind of nitty-gritty
policy questions and we're not always
going to agree
i've never heard dr fauci or dr wolinski
for that matter declare themselves to be
invincible i certainly am not
but
that should not mean that individuals
career public servants are subjected to
this kind of abuse thank you madam chair
thank you senator collins
mrs o'connell
i want to follow up on my previous
questions to you
because i don't feel frankly that i got
answers
i'm asking you specifically
how much money was diverted
from the testing budget
to deal with the surge
of
people including unaccompanied minors
illegally crossing
the southern border and how much money
was diverted
out of the funds allocated for the
strategic stockpile
thank you senator collins again all of
the funds as they were um
appropriated to the american rescue plan
for or for testing contact racing
and mitigation efforts of those funds
funds were used to test unaccompanied
children at the border and then to
mitigate the covet positive cases so
they wouldn't enter the community and
spread coven
which was a you know a use of the funds
that was allowed under the uh testing
contact tracing and mitigation uh
requirements
well you're still not answering my
question on the amount of money
that was used to
deal with the crisis at the southern
border so i will tell you that our
staff's investigation found
that
850 million dollars out of the testing
budget
and another
850 million dollars out of the
allocation for the stockpile were
instead used to deal with the crisis at
the southern border do do those numbers
sound right to you
senator i'll be happy to take that back
and discuss that with our
finance team to make sure that those
numbers are the same numbers that
they're tracking
well i have to say that it's interesting
to me that you knew all of the numbers
and i commend you for this that we're
going to community programs to schools
etc
but you can't tell me
how much
was
reallocated to deal with the crisis of
the at the southern border a crisis that
were it brought under control
we would have these funds for the
purposes that
they were intended
let me ask you further what do you mean
when you say
mitigation as supplied to the southern
border and the surge the unprecedented
surge of people crossing
thank you one of the important things
that we needed to do when we identified
a covered positive unaccompanied child
was to make sure for example they didn't
ride on the same bus to a shelter
with a coveted negative child so there
were additional costs for transportation
to keep the children separate to
mitigate spread as the statute allowed
us to spend those funds in addition
within the shelters it was necessary to
set up a separate room where coveted
positive unaccompanied children would
reside so they wouldn't interact with
the covid negative children and that
required additional uh you know
additional resources in those shelters
in order to keep them separate so when
the children entered the community with
their sponsors uh they were not bringing
covet into the communities
well i will tell you having visited the
southern border in late march
testing
was being done but people had been there
for weeks
at a time with no testing
and
there were people
adults who were released into the
community with no testing the fact it
remains that if we
had the southern border under control
we would be using
the 850 million dollars designated for
testing to buy more rapid tests
we would be using the money out of the
stockpile the 850 million for the
purposes for which it was intended
so i think that this is a problem
that has contributed
to the shortage of testing
the uncontrolled crisis at the border
and i also
am perplexed by the lack of federal
orders for tests between january and
september of 2021 which i know
from my experience in maine caused a
major manufacturer abbott
to lay off 400 workers that were
producing those tests because
it lacked the federal orders that makes
no sense to me and seems very
short-sighted
thank you
thank you senator uh senator
hickenlooper
great thank you madam chair
and again thank each of you for your
public service um
dr wolinski i wanted to talk to you just
for a moment about
genomic sequencing
even before coven 19 appeared colorado
colorado made a
genomic sequencing of diseases a high
priority and we're now i think one of
the leading states in detecting changes
as they
evolve in coving 19.
we test about 15 percent of all positive
covid tests uh i think that's still one
of the highest rates in the country
uh and we also monitor wastewater uh
for community detection
but so dr wellansky how would we or how
can we expand
genomics surveillance
and expand those capabilities in order
to try to stay ahead
of of existing but also future threats
um
covid 19 or otherwise how do we close a
gap between you know the states that are
heavily sequencing and following this
and those that aren't
yes thank you for
that and for your leadership in colorado
in genomic sequencing as i've mentioned
you know we need to have both numbers
and breadth and geographic distribution
in order to get a real um
good
view of what's happening genomic in
genomic sequencing so we need to sample
from state labs so we get samples from
every single lab we also get samples
from commercial labs which gives us a
lot of volume we have partnerships now
with um 19 i believe academic medical
centers in order to do so um and what we
do and and power our genomic sequencing
is so that we are able to detect a
sequence that's present at less than 0.1
so we scale up and based on the number
of cases that we have we scale up or
scale down our genomic sequencing so we
can detect it and what we were able to
do with omicron is when we saw the
footprint of the s gene target failure
and pcrs a similar footprint as alpha we
were able to do targeted enhanced
surveillance of sequences that actually
had that initial footprint and able to
identify sequences even before they
reached that point one percent threshold
so as you said we can we can scale this
up in wastewater we're able to
potentially scale it up for purposes of
antimicrobial resistance for foodborne
outbreaks and many other things which
we're really looking forward to doing
now that we've established this
incredible capacity
right great that's perfect um
mr connell uh i want to ask you a
question in terms of the we've talked a
lot about uh the distribution of tests
and whether it's schools or workplaces
hospitals um
and we talked about how they're at this
moment we don't have enough tests out
there
um and we're not getting results quickly
enough uh in terms of the distribution
of tests
on a national level
we're still obviously working on a
system i know the administration is hard
at work on this
but some states like colorado already
have systems in place where tests are
being mailed directly to people
in their home
and i guess i'm
i'm not i don't know is the federal
government working with states like
colorado and trying to
uh look at those systems already in
place and how do we integrate the
federal system with those states
absolutely thank you senator that's
terrific what colorado is doing
we have invested 29 billion dollars with
the state so they could set up such
testing programs however they saw fit
and we are seeing states like colorado
use
use those funds to be able to do exactly
what we're hoping to do on a national
level
we are in the process as we've talked
about today setting this up working with
the u.s postal service as the federal
government uh we will allow uh american
households to order and have them
delivered to their house as well i
imagine uh that we will these will be in
addition to what
colorado is able to provide and we want
to have as many tests of course
available to all americans as possible
so if colorado is already doing it
that's terrific i'm sure we will learn
some lessons from the experiences you've
had in your state and apply those to
this national initiative
great thank you on that and then just
real quickly um dr fauci uh
we've heard from
dr wolinski was just talking about how
we integrate the
aggregation of large amounts of data
and we've had a discussion
about
israel versus south africa
it really is a question of how do we
take
my question is is how do we take
information from global sources
and
you know learn from those countries who
are ahead of us on the curve make sure
that uh we're learning from their
experiences
and i think how can we do a better job
working with our international partners
to make sure that we are prepared for
the next greek letter
yeah well thank you very much
excellent question and we are just
actually doing that
every week
to 10 days i have a long phone call
with chris witte and patrick valens who
are the two leading medical and
scientific advisers to the prime
minister of england
to get a feel what's going on there we
have regular phone calls with our
israeli colleagues and every saturday or
sunday morning depending upon what it is
dr wolinski and i and others are on the
phone with our south african colleagues
so we are in literally constant
communication with them
great thank you thank you
senator marshall
the american people
you know my family all of our families
are struggling as this pandemic
continues to drag on with no end in
sight
the words i hear every day multiple
times each day continue to resonate an
echo in my mind as i said here words
like i'm tired
confused
burnt out scared and frustrated
the list goes on
what's making the situation worse are
the officials leading our nation's
coveted response going on national
television and contradicting each other
and of course some supreme court
justices are spreading misinformation as
well
dr wolinski this past week you
recommended asymptomatic people be able
to return to work after five days
but dr fauci ambiguously corrected you
on national television and suggested
folks needed a test before return
how does it make you feel when dr fauci
or someone like justice sotomayor
upstages a previous statement or
policies of yours
blatantly contradicts and undermines
your guidance or offers false claims
that cause more confusion for the
american people
thank you senator um i have the great
honor of leading the agency of 12 000
public health servants in this country
and we work collaboratively with tens of
thousands of public health officials
around the country to provide guidance i
also get to work with a cova 19 task
force that is full of a
multi-disciplinary group of people with
diverse expertise from immunology to
drug regulation to epidemiology um this
science is moving really quickly and i
know you will appreciate that it's
moving fast and it is changing and it's
right your audience
to convey that science i'll move on
the fda has recently set up protocols
for monoclonal antibodies and antiviral
pharmaceuticals to be prioritized based
upon race
dr woodcock has the cdc or fda done a
multiple regression analysis
on race to see if indeed it's an
independent factor for increased
morbidity and mortality and if it hasn't
don't you think zip code would actually
be more predictive wouldn't it make
sense to prioritize these antivirals and
testing for that matter to senior
citizens and those with significant
comorbidities regardless of race
especially if the multiple regression
analysis proves my opinion
dr woodcock
what fda did was to recommend um if that
you know that people at high risk
would be
candidates for these products did you do
a multi-regression analysis
on this independent factor
we did not
okay we did not we don't make those kind
of recommendations we make but you can
do studies right the fda and cdc can do
studies to see if it's truly an
independent factor or if not truly the
issue should be about your comorbidities
and your age
so
dr fauci according to forbes
you have an annual salary in 2020 was
434 thousand dollars
you oversee over five billion dollars in
federal research grants
as the highest paid employee in the
entire federal government
yes or no would you be willing to submit
to congress and the public
a financial disclosure that includes
your past and current investments after
all your colleague dr wilinski and every
member of congress submits a financial
disclosure that includes their
investments
i don't understand why you're asking me
that question my financial disclosure
is public knowledge and has been so
for the last 37 years or so of 35 years
big tech giants are doing an incredible
job of keeping it from being public uh
we'll continue to look for it where
would we find it
all you have to do is ask for it
i i you're so misinformed it's
extraordinary why am i going to have to
why am i as important this is a huge
issue wouldn't you agree with me that
that you have a you see things before
members of congress would see him so
that there's a an arab appearance that
that maybe some shenanigans are going on
you know i don't think that's i assume
that that's not the case are you talking
about the case
my financial disclosures are public
knowledge and have been so you are
getting amazingly wrong information
so
i cannot find them our office cannot
find them where would they be at their
public knowledge
where it is totally accessible to you if
you want it for the public is it
accessible to the public
to the public right we look
totally incorrect we look forward to
reviewing it senator marshall dr fauci
has answered jude his public information
and he's happy to give it to you if you
would ask senator moran
chairwoman thank you um
i know this has been talked about i've
watched a bit of the hearing from my
office
this morning and into this afternoon but
would you highlight for me i suppose
this is for dr woodcock
lots of funding
i think adequate funding
certainly knowledge about
winter months would bring an increase in
cases
what what's the challenge in not being
better prepared for access to testing in
home
uh and elsewhere
and how soon will that change
i i don't think that's i think that's a
question for for uh
assistant secretary mcconnell
but i would tell you fda has approved or
authorized over 400 tests or collection
systems just for covid
we've approved authorized 15
over-the-counter tests but it's capacity
that we're talking about here
production capacity so there's no what
you're telling me dr woodcock is there's
no
problem with the fda approval of tests
it's the manufacturing process and the
supply chain
we could do more with more resources
we have authorized over 2 000 different
device products including the
the 400
test related products in two years so
that's an incredible increase in the
workload and we really appreciate the
funding that congress has provided
however
the
test manufacturers many of them give us
incomplete results we have to go back
and forth with them the itap program
that we are doing with nih for home
testing i think we'll improve that
tremendously that's a big advance
forward
but
there's also the matter of production
capacity with this huge surge and so
many more people becoming infected
is there a separate fda
um results process in which the test is
read and determined positive or negative
there's no challenges there
in that process
that's what the itap
program over at nih is doing they're
actually doing the laboratory and
clinical testing for the manufacturers
and then they send us the data and so
it's standardized and it's a panel and
that is really accelerates our ability
to get these authorized very quickly as
i said earlier we've authorized them
within two days of getting the data from
the itap program so as that that's a
tremendous setup that i think is really
beneficial where we have standardized
testing
by scientists in the government and that
enables the manufacturers to get their
products through very fast thank you ms
o'connell
thank you senator and just to pick up
where dr woodcock left off once those
tests are authorized asper uh reaches
out to the manufacturers to make sure
that we're optimizing uh the
manufacturing capability so that part is
sort of a seamless process that we have
but all of the work we're doing in
testing in this administration is in
service of four priorities one to expand
the number of testing sites that are
available to uh to expand the number of
tests that are available that's the part
that i'm working on to increase capacity
three the kinds of tests that are
available that's the part dr woodcock
just discussed and then to help lower
the cost of tests
uh and is there um
is there a problem i don't i don't know
whether the testing devices are
manufactured domestically do we have
another challenge of the importation of
tests
as we did with masks and gowns and
gloves
we continue to look for tests wherever
we can find them and we have encouraged
actually some test manufacturers that
are approved in europe
to apply for fda approval here in the
united states
so i do anticipate we will have some
importation of tests at some point but
we've used the defense production act
authorities 12 times
to support the domestic manufacture of
tests and to priority rate
those orders so we can increase the
supplies and manufacturing capacity here
in the us in the third of a minute that
i have left
we've changed i think our view on mask
recently
and we're emphasizing n95s
is there any intentions to um
is there a plan to manufacture
additional 95 mass so they're more
available
is there a way to make them more
comfortable
um
i'll leave that that's the crux to my
question
we continue to support the manufacture
of n95 masks we have 737 million in the
strategic national stockpile all sourced
from 12 domestic manufacturers so we're
continuing to support that
we are also in the process of
of putting out an agreement for warm
base manufacturing so we're able to keep
this capacity that we currently have
going even when demand diminishes
so that's all underway right now as far
as fit and style and how they work i'm
sure you know colleagues at the table
are probably have various pieces of
their programs that might be
participating to that effort and
consulting with the manufacturers on how
that will work thank you thank you move
to senator tuberville thank you very
much just very quickly you know i know
there's plenty of misinformation on both
sides
uh you know when it comes to covid you
know but i i would say this you know the
fear-mongering on the left is and i'm
gonna give you a couple questions here
about this it has made the matter is
much worse dr fauci i just want to ask
you this from my constituents back in
alabama
ivormectin
40-year drug now my constituents read
this they hear about it and all this
40-year drug they call it a wonder drug
it's about a nicola of tablet
it's done wonders supposedly in india
and several other places
and then you have this new antiviral
pill that we're coming out
and my constituents saying this thing's
going to cost five six seven hundred
dollars each
could you give me a rundown on between
the difference in those two what you
think about them get it on record here
so we you know i can tell my people back
home this is what dr fauci says yeah so
paxlovid the drug from pfizer
has shown in a randomized
placebo-controlled trial
to be highly effective to the point of
89 percent almost ninety percent
what's it called
pax loved okay it's made by pfizer
and has been shown in a very well
controlled randomized placebo control
trial
that if you take that drug compared to
the placebo within the first three to
five days within the first three days
you have about an eighty nine percent
chance of preventing you from going to
the hospital or dying
there were no deaths in the black pla in
the paxlovid group and there were
several deaths in the placebo group
that's pecslovid ivormectum has had
non-controlled trials suggesting that it
might be effective mostly anecdotal
the cdc excuse me the nih guidelines
panel
have looked at that data and felt
there's not sufficient evidence to say
that it works or it doesn't did wh
recommend strongly against it and
suggests that it might actually be
harmful
the the nih
uh active studies are doing a whole
bunch of studies with iremectum as well
as others to try and settle it once and
for all to prevent people
from taking it if it doesn't work
because it could be toxic so there's a
world of difference between ivormectum
and paxlovid but this is a 40-year drug
and we're talking about one that's just
now coming on the market so
uh we actually know that much about
this pfizer drug i wish they'd come up
with a lot easier names for their yeah
they always do that they they fool me
too with the names coach but
it is what it is um the fact is
i think it's it's it's kind of a
mis comparison to say one is a 40-year
drug and one is
a drug that was just discovered it was
just discovered but it was shown in a
very well controlled clinical trial to
be highly effective even though
ivormectum is a good drug for some
parasites it has not been shown in a
well-controlled placebo-controlled trial
to be effective in covid
okay thank you dr wolinski
i don't know if anybody's asked this
question i just want to get cleared up
our supreme court justice last week
looking into the situation with the
mandate
uh
justice omar said there's a hundred
thousand children
that are sick as we speak with omicron
and a lot of them are serious in
hospital is that true true or false
i don't have the number that of children
in the hospital right now it's likely
less than a hundred thousand yeah and
and justice breyer said that
you know that if we continue to delay
this ruling
that we're gonna have 750 000 more that
are not vaccinated uh infected a day i
mean
does that make sense to you
what i can tell you is our children
between the ages of zero and four are
one of the only places where our
hospitalization rates are currently
rising um and that children who are in
the hospital are un generally
unvaccinated not uniformly but generally
unvaccinated um and that's true for not
just our zero to four who are obviously
ineligible but also true for our five to
11 year olds as well as our 12 to 17
year olds
thank you well thank you all for being
here today thank you very much thank you
madam chair thank you so much i have one
final question for miss o'connell dr
wolenski
and that's regarding education in the
past we have seen school districts that
serve a significant number of students
of color or those in low-income or rural
areas that are facing great challenges
in accessing resources they need to
serve our
our students how is the federal
government working now to make sure that
states are equitably distributing tests
and necessary resources like masks to
all school districts particularly those
that serve predominantly students from
families with low income students of
color or rural students
and ms o'connell start with you
thank you chair murray equity is woven
into all the work that we're doing in
this response it's something that we
are remain focused on including making
sure that schools across all states are
able to access the tools and resources
they need
we gave 10 billion dollars as you know
from the american rescue plan for
schools to be able to set up uh their
funding programs we're also testing
programs uh we've also made it possible
through operation expanded testing which
dr welinski can talk more about where we
have regional hubs where schools can
contract directly with labs to run their
programs for them that was designed for
schools that might not otherwise have
resources to be able to manage a testing
program on their own in addition we're
making tests available through the
federally qualified health centers and
rural health centers
um and we've done that with masks as
well earlier in the year
thank you
dr
yeah and that maybe i'll just pick up
exactly where asper o'connell has uh put
down so um you know our our icap program
our increased community access to
testing program does place tests in
pharmacies and socially vulnerable
social vulnerability indices that are
high that's by design tests in federally
qualified health care centers and
community centers just as
the assistant secretary mentioned we
also continue to support screening tests
at no cost to child care centers k to 12
schools and congregate settings through
exactly the program that the asper
mentioned operation expanded testing we
prioritize high schools that have in all
schools that have high social
vulnerability and we have a website now
that's active where you can enroll okay
thank you uh
senator i understand you have two
additional questions
madam chair
um this is for uh dr woodcock and ms
o'connell
it's my understanding that prior to
omnicron
barta informed some therapeutic
manufacturers that they would no longer
be supporting additional work on new
therapies because there's no longer an
unmet need
which may impact whether and how fda
prioritizes reviewing such therapies
did barta and fda change course on this
policy once the omicron variant was
discovered in november
barta's decision to put that
notification out was
in light of the fact that the
therapeutics development was moved over
to operation warp speed and barta was
supporting uh the therapies that were
being developed through the warp speed
effort so it was a way of of combining
the funding that was available to be
able to move the therapies through
faster barta never stopped supporting
therapy work
but i'll let dr woodcock
yeah there is we still regard there is a
extreme unmet medical need for
therapeutics at most stages of the
disease
particularly the late stages where we
still don't have
interventions and so people are dying in
the
late stage of disease getting into the
icu going on the ventilator so of course
we've have 670
inds that we've been
clinical protocols that are ongoing to
my knowledge so their robust development
is still ongoing uh in the therapeutic
area so how much
how much funding has barda allocated
to therapeutics this year and how much
is left
to spend
i'll have to go back and check that on
on the actual development we've spent a
lot of funds this year on the
procurement of the therapeutics that
have already been developed but be more
than happy to bring that number to you
and your staff this is i'm talking about
the development end of it
because there's
there's a firm belief out there that
berta went to the industry and said
we're not sporting this anymore
uh they didn't say this got moved over
to
operation warp speed which by the way
doesn't exist anymore
but they said barta said we're not
supporting therapeutics because there's
not an unmet need that's what the
industry heard i'd love for you to
clarify that for me last thing dr
woodcock since we did discuss
the uh
point of care and at home testing
i just happened to come up with a chart
that fda
uh put out not long ago so let me just
and you you're probably familiar with it
one's
molecular one's antigen and one's
serology
and for the molecular and the antigen uh
point if you if you
test yes for point of care or at home
that kicks you to the right the next box
is high manufacturing capacity if your
answer is no there it kicks you down to
an fda intends to decline
box there's no option
so
if you're not a high
manufacturing
test
then fda is going to decline
to review
boy
i gotta tell you i think this is a huge
mistake
um now if you tell me that you've got a
couple hundred tests that fall into the
high manufacturing capacity right now at
the fda
where we're
you've got the luxury of being able to
kick out new innovative companies that
haven't solved their manufacturing yet
um
by all means tell me that's the case
that there are a couple hundred right
now miss mcconnell's struggling
to buy 500 million tests we're
47 maybe 50 million there that leaves
another 450 million to purchase
and and we're going to distributors
trying to buy their inventory
not to manufacturers trying to buy their
capacity something's not right here guys
on testing
and i will tell you
the
current administration's chief of staff
got it right in 2020
march and he said
testing's broken testing's broken
testing's broken i just say to all of
you right now testing's broken
and ms o'connell i think the
responsibility falls to the asper i
wrote the law
if
in the case of cdc they were the delay
to begin with
but to acquire testing that falls in
your lane
and
i i for the life of me can't figure out
after 82 billion dollars
except for somebody sitting down and
saying well we just don't need those
tests we don't need to buy them
uh how you could let abbott
close two lines
because there wasn't any business these
are some of the most premier
manufacturers in the world that we've
let get out of the mass manufacturing of
home test business
if i'm wrong tell me i am i respect all
four of you in a huge way
but i also
express
my disapproval
very quickly and that's what i'm doing
today anything you want to add to that
mr connolly please thank you ranking
member let me just clarify of course
that the initial contracts you're
speaking of uh towards the 500 million
were the available inventory that these
distributors had these are the
distributor contracts the manufacturer
contracts are currently being worked you
will see that capacity come on quickly
we just haven't been able to land the
contracts uh to draft the contracts as
quickly as the distributors but they are
coming
my suggestion in the future
is that when you guys huddle inside the
covid team
try to get the administration to refrain
from making these proclamations
until we've got the product
until we know who we're negotiating with
we're now three weeks since the
president said we're going to buy
500 million tests
we have 50 million currently contracted
i don't know how long it's going to take
to get the rest of the contract this is
not dissimilar to when we when we went
out and said we're going to booster
everybody in america yet we rolled it
out with just people over 60 to start
with and then we started moving down
um and now we're begging people to get
boosted which is where we should have
been on day one because we had the
product available
but
listen i
you guys have a tough job
and i don't know of anything else
congress can do than try to create the
statutory framework that you can work in
to do your job which exists
or provide the funding to allow you to
acquire
those are the only two things we can do
other than bitching gripe when it
doesn't happen as quickly as we'd like
but tony i i really respect you and i'm
sorry you and your family are going
through what you're going through
but please understand
we go through that every time we go home
with millions of people in north
carolina
millions that
believe the
bad information that's out there
millions of people that have a loved one
in the hospital but there's no
monoclonal form to take
uh millions of people who are
unvaccinated probably wish today they
had gotten vaccinated probably wish they
had gotten boosted
but they're now in the icu and their
wife or husband or daughter is calling
us and saying what do i do
so
we're here to support
what you need
tell us
but don't think
that we're just going to sit here and
print money
without a full accountability of where
it has gone
and i i hope the secretary's listening
to that conversation today senator blunt
and i said give us a full audited
accounting of the 82 billion dollars and
we'll entertain
uh additional funding for testing
that was 10 days ago
i'm not sure when we're going to get it
or if we're going to get it
but it's conditional
and this is the most powerful person on
the other side of the appropriations
and i think she knows i'm serious on
this one um
there's there's got to be accountability
on the money and the way it's spent
thank you for being here thank you madam
chairman thank you i want to thank uh
truly thank all of our witnesses today
dr wolenski dr fatchi dr woodcock
assistant secretary o'connell we all
know this is a very difficult
challenging changing time and you've all
been through it for a long time i i
think you do understand the frustration
i'm sure you all have it as well as
where we are we all want to find
solutions and we stand at your back to
be able to provide those but thank you
so much for uh answering all our
questions this is really an important
conversation about the threat of the new
covert variant
or whatever the next one is and about
the path forward for our pandemic
response and we really do appreciate all
the work you and all the people in your
agencies do
so for any senators who wish to ask
additional questions questions for the
record will be due in 10 business days
january 26 at 5 pm and with that the
committee does stand adjourned